This episode is brought to you by Lloyds, which has been backing British ambition for over 250 years. Now, when you think about it, every dynasty in history has boiled down to two important elements, aspiration and action. And a classic example of this from British history, the rise of the House of Wessex, the family of Alfred the Great and his heirs, who, between. them established the United Kingdom of England. Yeah, it's a great story, isn't it, Tom? Great lesson in leadership, I think, for anybody. So Alfred and his heirs, they marry idealism and pragmatism. They're brilliant at alliances. They're brilliant at managing power. They're brilliance, of course, at managing their money, which is a key part of political leadership.
本期节目由劳埃德银行（Lloyds）赞助播出，该银行两百五十多年来一直支持着英国人的雄心壮志。说起来，历史上每一个王朝的兴衰归根结底都离不开两个重要因素：抱负与行动。英国历史上有一个经典的例子，那就是威塞克斯王朝的崛起，也就是阿尔弗雷德大帝及其继承人的家族，他们共同建立了英格兰联合王国。没错，这是一个很棒的故事，对吧，汤姆？我认为这对任何人来说都是很好的领导力课程。所以，阿尔弗雷德和他的继承人们将理想主义与实用主义结合在了一起。他们擅长结盟，擅长驾驭权力，当然，他们也擅长理财，而这正是政治领导力的关键所在。
And of course, we are all reaping the rewards of their wisdom and foresight. When it's time to make your next move, you can bank on Lloyd's to be ready, where you're you are. Because from new businesses to new homes and new life chapters, backed by generations of hope and ambition, you can see, Tom, why 14 million people trust Lloyd's to help make their dreams a reality. Based on Lloyd's internal customer data from March 26. Hers is the head upon which all the ends of the world are come. And the eyes. And the eyelids are a little weary. It is a beauty wrought out from within upon the flesh, the deposit little cell by cell of strange thoughts and fantastic reveries and exquisite passions. Set it for a moment,
当然，我们都在享受着他们智慧与远见所带来的成果。当您需要进行下一步规划时，您可以信赖劳埃德银行，无论您身在何处，我们随时为您准备。因为从新创企业到新居所，再到人生的新篇章，在几代人希望与雄心的支持下，汤姆，您就能明白为什么一千四百万客户信任劳埃德银行，并让我们帮助他们实现梦想。（数据基于劳埃德银行2023年3月26日的内部客户数据。）她是万物终结所归之处的化身。她的双眼，她的眼睑略显疲惫。这是一种由内而外在肌肤上雕琢出的美，是奇异思想、奇幻遐想和绝妙激情一点一滴沉淀而成的结晶。试着将她，
beside one of those white Greek goddesses or beautiful women of antiquity, and how would they be troubled by this beauty into which the soul with all its maladies has passed? All the thoughts and experience of the world have edged and moulded there in that which they have of power to refine and make expressive the outward form, the animalism of Greece, the lust of Rome, the mysticism of the Middle Age with its spiritual ambition and imaginative loves, the return of the pagan world, the sins of the Borgias. She is older than the rocks among which she sits. Like the vampire, she has been dead many times and learned the secrets of the grave, and has been a dine. dive her in deep seas and keeps their fallen day about her and trafficked for strange webs with
与那些古希腊的白石女神或古代的美女并列，她们怎能不被这种灵魂历经沧桑后所呈现的美所困扰？世间所有的思想与经历都在那里磨砺与塑造，赋予了她提炼并表达外在形式的力量：希腊的动物性、罗马的欲望、中世纪带有精神抱负与浪漫幻想的神秘主义、异教世界的回归、波吉亚家族的罪恶。她比她所坐落的岩石还要古老。像吸血鬼一样，她曾多次死去，知晓坟墓的秘密，曾潜入深海，带着沉没的白昼，与东方商人交易奇异的丝网，
eastern merchants, and as Lida was the mother of Helen of Troy, and as St Anne, the mother of Mary, and all this has been to her, but as the sound of liars and flutes, and lives only in the delicacy with which it has moulded the changing lineaments and tinged the eyelids and hands. So that was the Victorian art critic Walter Pater in very Victorian prose. And he was describing one of the most celebrated women who's ever existed. Her face familiar to probably not millions of people, but hundreds of millions, if not billions. A woman who's often regarded as the ultimate fam fatal. A woman into whom is poured, certainly according to Walter Pater, every woman who has ever existed.
正如丽达是特洛伊海伦的母亲，正如圣安妮是玛丽的母亲，这一切对她而言，不过是里拉琴与长笛的声响，只存在于那塑造了她多变面容、晕染了眼睑与双手的细腻之中。刚才那段极具维多利亚时代风格的文字出自维多利亚时代的艺术评论家沃尔特·佩特之手。他所描述的是历史上最著名的女性之一。她的面孔或许不为数百万，而是数亿甚至数十亿人所熟知。她常被视为终极的“蛇蝎美人”。按照沃尔特·佩特的说法，她身上汇聚了古往今来所有的女性。
Beautiful, mysterious, exotic, irisodes. erotic and dangerous. Well, I say a woman, he's describing actually a painting of a woman, a painting, which is surely the most well-known painting in the world, the Mona Lisa. Tom, the Mona Lisa. You a fan? Well, I've always taken it so for granted that I wouldn't really have called myself a fan. Its fame is of itself such a fascinating thing that that's what prompted me to think that this might be a good topic for the rest of history. But having plunged into the deep waters of the Mona Lisa's history and explored the rocks that are older than time among which she sits, I am now definitely a fan, yes. Oh, tremendous. It's a painting
美丽、神秘、异域风情、令人着迷、危险。好吧，我说的是一位女性，但他实际上是在描述一幅女性的肖像画，这幅画无疑是世界上最著名的画作——《蒙娜丽莎》。汤姆，《蒙娜丽莎》。你是她的粉丝吗？嗯，我一直觉得它太理所当然了，以至于我不会称自己为粉丝。它的名气本身就是一件如此迷人的事情，这促使我想到这可能是“历史的其余部分”节目的一个好话题。但在深入研究了《蒙娜丽莎》的历史，探索了她所坐落的那些比时间更古老的岩石之后，我现在绝对是她的粉丝了。哦，太棒了。这是一幅
that is a lot more interesting than I had thought. I mean, I think basically I've kind of been anisitized to its beauty, and I guess that's true of lots of people. You kind of see it as a fridge magnet rather than this painting, don't you? But it's, it is fascinating. And, And one of the reasons for its fame is actually that passage that you read. It's one of the most kind of famous passages of purple prose in the whole of English literature. He wrote that in 1869. Back when he wrote that, the Mona Lisa was not remotely as famous as it is today. And the reason for that is that the paintings that had cut through in the Victorian period were those that were very easily copied.
比我预想中要有趣得多的画作。我的意思是，我觉得自己基本上已经对它的美“麻木”了，我想很多人也是这样。你可能把它看作是一个冰箱贴，而不是一幅画，对吧？但它确实非常迷人。它之所以出名，原因之一其实就是你刚才读的那段话。那是整个英语文学中最著名的华丽辞藻之一。他写于1869年。在他写下那段话的时候，《蒙娜丽莎》的名气远没有今天这么大。原因在于，在维多利亚时代，那些容易被复制的画作才更容易流行。
So paintings with kind of clear boundaries. but there's a quality to the Mona Lisa which seems to defy reproduction. It's actually very, very hard to reproduce. And this wasn't for want of trying. People have been trying to capture the essence of this extraordinary painting right from the beginning. So there's a famous copy of it in the Prado, which was done while the Mona Lisa had only just been painted. But it doesn't get its essence at all. Then going into the 18th into the 19th century,
所以，那些轮廓清晰的画作更容易传播。但《蒙娜丽莎》有一种似乎无法被复制的特质。它实际上非常、非常难以复制。这并不是因为人们没有尝试过。从一开始，人们就一直在试图捕捉这幅非凡画作的精髓。普拉多博物馆里就有一幅著名的临摹作品，是在《蒙娜丽莎》刚画完不久后完成的。但它根本没有捕捉到精髓。到了18世纪和19世纪，
they try and do it with copper plate prints. Then of course, photographs, but even photographers, apparently, to begin with, struggled to capture the Mona Lisa in their photographs because the technology just wasn't up to reproducing it. And it's only by the 1880s that photography has evolved technologically enough to allow for kind of accurate photographs of the Mona Lisa to be reproduced on a mass scale. And as a result of that, of course, the image of the Mona Lisa gets spread across Europe, across the world. And I think it is, I mean, you said maybe it's the most recognizable painting.
人们尝试用铜版画来复制它。后来当然是摄影，但起初，摄影师们显然也难以在照片中捕捉到《蒙娜丽莎》，因为当时的技术还不足以还原它。直到19世纪80年代，摄影技术才发展到足以大规模复制《蒙娜丽莎》的精确照片。结果就是，《蒙娜丽莎》的形象传遍了欧洲，传遍了全世界。我想，正如你所说，它可能是辨识度最高的画作。
I would say there's no doubt about it at all. It is the most recognizable painting that has ever been in the whole of history. And yet, at first glance, well, I mean, as you say, at first glance, you barely notice it because it's ubiquitous. So you don't really think anything of it. It's part of the furniture. But when you look at it, there's nothing. remarkable about it. There's nothing exceptional about it compared with, for example, some of the paintings that you did on the Restis History Club miniseries in Laura Cumming. A painting like
我会说毫无疑问，它是整个历史上辨识度最高的画作。然而，乍一看，正如你所说，你几乎注意不到它，因为它无处不在。所以你并没有真正去想它。它就像是家具的一部分。但当你仔细观察时，会发现它并没有什么特别之处。与你在“历史的其余部分”俱乐部迷你系列中与劳拉·卡明讨论的一些画作相比，它并没有什么非凡之处。比如
Las Maninas by Balafcathfketh is much more, you know, appears much more nuanced, much more layered, much more sophisticated. The Mona Lisa is just a woman sitting on a balcony looking out at you. What's so special do you think about this that makes it hard to reproduce? Before we get into that, we should just describe it for the three people perhaps in the world I've never seen it. So there's something distinctive about her pose. Distinctive certainly when it was painted. So she's kind of sitting in profile, but her torso has turned around so that her face is
委拉斯开兹的《宫娥》看起来要微妙得多，层次感更丰富，也更复杂。《蒙娜丽莎》只是一个坐在阳台上看着你的女人。你认为它有什么特别之处，导致它难以复制？在我们深入探讨之前，我们应该为世界上那三个可能没见过它的人描述一下。她的姿势有些独特。在它被绘制时确实很独特。她侧身坐着，但躯干转了过来，所以她的脸
almost staring into the eyes of the person who is standing in front of the painting. Her face is pale. She's got brown eyes. She's got quite full cheeks. She's certainly not thin. She has no eyebrows. She has long, delicately curling hair, but this is covered by an almost translucent veil.
几乎是在直视站在画作前的人的眼睛。她的脸很苍白。她有一双棕色的眼睛。她的脸颊相当丰满。她肯定不瘦。她没有眉毛。她留着长长的、精致卷曲的头发，但被一层近乎透明的面纱覆盖着。
She has a very plain, dark dress. She has no jewelry, no adornments of any kind. And of course, the most famous thing about her expression, probably the most famous thing about the entire painting, is her smile. And we'll be coming to that. Yeah, people go. about that but I mean I don't even think it really is much of a smile if someone looked to me like
她穿着一件非常朴素的深色连衣裙。她没有佩戴任何珠宝或装饰品。当然，她表情中最著名的一点，可能也是整幅画中最著名的一点，就是她的微笑。我们稍后会谈到这一点。是的，人们对此议论纷纷，但我甚至不认为那算得上是一个真正的微笑。如果有人那样看着我，
that and said I'm smiling at you I'd be like are you really that is part of the mystery is that people respond to the smile in many different ways but just before we come to that the one thing about the painting that is overtly fantastical is the landscape against which the Mona Lisa is set so this is a landscape that's very barren it's it's kind of wild it's tortured you have jagged mountains rocks lakes And the only signs of a kind of human physical presence, there's a winding road and there's an arch bridge crossing a river. Tom, I commend you for this because you made me look at the painting already in a new way.
然后说“我在对你微笑”，我会想：你真的在笑吗？这就是谜团的一部分，人们对这种微笑的反应各不相同。但在谈到这一点之前，画作中唯一明显带有奇幻色彩的部分是《蒙娜丽莎》背后的风景。这是一个非常荒凉的景观，它很狂野，很扭曲，有锯齿状的山脉、岩石和湖泊。而人类物理存在的唯一迹象，是一条蜿蜒的道路和一座横跨河流的拱桥。汤姆，我称赞你，因为你已经让我以一种全新的方式看待这幅画了。
I've never even noticed the background, to be honest. I'm sorry. Okay, so if you're looking at it, the striking thing about the quality of the paint, and I think this is the reason why it is so difficult to reproduce, isn't the subject. It's the way in which this woman and the landscape have been painted. Because there's a very distinctive quality to it, and it's traditionally described as Fomato, as smoky. And the effect of this is brilliantly described by certainly the leading British expert on the Mona Lisa, who is Martin Kemp, who isn't the basis from Spandau Ballet.
老实说，我以前从未注意过背景。抱歉。好吧，如果你仔细观察，颜料质量中最引人注目的地方——我认为这就是它如此难以复制的原因——不在于主体，而在于这个女人和风景的绘制方式。因为它有一种非常独特的特质，传统上被描述为“晕涂法”（Sfumato），即烟雾状。这种效果被《蒙娜丽莎》的权威英国专家马丁·坎普出色地描述过，他可不是斯潘道芭蕾乐队（Spandau Ballet）的那位。
Not him. I think he's the professor of art at Oxford or something. You know, you're a Oxford doctorate. Yeah, he actually is the same person. So Martin Kemp describes the effect of Sumato as being the paradox of a precisely rendered indefiniteness. So it's not precise. I mean, there's a sense of kind of smokiness to it. Now, how do you render indefiniteness precisely?
不是他。我想他是牛津大学的艺术教授之类的。你知道，你是牛津博士。是的，他确实是同一个人。所以马丁·坎普将“晕涂法”的效果描述为“精确渲染的不确定性”的悖论。所以它并不精确。我的意思是，它有一种烟雾缭绕的感觉。那么，你如何精确地渲染不确定性呢？
This is the kind of question that already, by the beginning of the 19th century, was puzzling German idealist philosophers. So let's quote the most famous German idealist philosopher who is Hegel and he was lecturing in the 1820s on the Renaissance. Great to get Hegel on the show. Great to have Hegel back. So he wrote, here is evident a supreme rounding. Nowhere is that any harsh or sharp line transition is everywhere. Light and shadow are not effective as purely direct light and shadow but they both shine into one another just as an inner force works throughout an external Now, what that means in practical terms for the impact of this portrait of Mona Lisa is that the corners of her eyes and of her mouth are blurred.
这正是19世纪初困扰德国唯心主义哲学家的问题。让我们引用最著名的德国唯心主义哲学家黑格尔，他在19世纪20年代讲授文艺复兴时曾提到过。很高兴能在节目中请到黑格尔。很高兴黑格尔能回来。他写道：“这里展现了一种极致的圆融。没有任何生硬或尖锐的线条，过渡无处不在。光与影并非作为纯粹直接的光影起作用，而是两者相互交融，就像一种内在的力量贯穿于外部。”那么，对于《蒙娜丽莎》肖像的影响来说，这意味着她眼角和嘴角的线条是模糊的。
It's hard to get an exact sense of what they actually look like. And as we've mentioned, there are no visible eyebrows. And this makes it difficult to read her expression. And you've already touched on the most famous puzzle. Is there a smile at all? If it is a smile, is she looking happy? Is she looking sad? Is it a knowing smile?
很难准确判断它们看起来到底是什么样。正如我们提到的，没有可见的眉毛。这使得解读她的表情变得困难。你已经触及了最著名的谜题：她到底有没有在笑？如果那是微笑，她看起来是快乐的吗？她是悲伤的吗？这是一个意味深长的微笑吗？
Is it a modest smile? Is this the smile of a Florentine matron? Or is it the smile of a vampire who is older than the rocks among which she sits? See, to me, do you know, I recognise that smile straight away. It's the weak smile of somebody who's heard a joke about the Kaiser a thousand times. It's thinking, I should never have come to this rest of history get together. is awful. Well, you see, there is the power of the sphermato, because each person will see in the smile what he or she, what they fear, or perhaps desire, who knows. But certainly this is where
这是一个谦逊的微笑吗？这是佛罗伦萨贵妇的微笑吗？还是一个比她所坐落的岩石还要古老的吸血鬼的微笑？你看，对我来说，我一眼就能认出那个微笑。那是某人听了一千遍关于德皇的笑话后露出的那种无力的微笑。心里想着：我真不该来参加这个“历史的其余部分”聚会，太糟糕了。好吧，你看，这就是“晕涂法”的力量，因为每个人都会在微笑中看到他或她所恐惧的，或者也许是所渴望的东西，谁知道呢？但毫无疑问，这就是
I think Walter Pater is coming in with his notion of her as, you know, a kind of timeless, infinite, vampiric figure. The fact that there is a mystery to her, that her smile is something elusive and enigmatic and potentially tantalizing. And it's this that really since the 19th century has made the Mona Lisa seem almost a sinister figure in the imaginings of many people. And the painting to be something that contains codes, clues, directions to something that seems to lurk just beyond human comprehension. And this is an idea that, of course, is still going incredibly strong and friend of the show Dan Brown, he's notoriously all over it.
我认为沃尔特·佩特引入了他关于她作为一个永恒、无限、吸血鬼般形象的观点的地方。她身上存在着一种神秘感，她的微笑是难以捉摸、神秘莫测且潜在地诱人的。正是这一点，自19世纪以来，让《蒙娜丽莎》在许多人的想象中显得几乎是一个阴险的人物。这幅画似乎包含着密码、线索和指向某种潜伏在人类理解力之外的事物的方向。这个想法当然至今仍然非常流行，节目的老朋友丹·布朗对此可是深谙此道。
So in the Da Vinci Code, the Mona Lisa, he says, embodies the sacred feminine. And in the plot of the Da Vinci Code, the Mona Lisa is in the Louvre behind its stained glass window and a clue is found written in blood on this stained glass window. And even though the Mona Lisa, it actually doesn't feature very prominently in the plot of the divinci
所以在《达芬奇密码》中，他说《蒙娜丽莎》体现了“神圣女性”。在《达芬奇密码》的情节中，《蒙娜丽莎》被安置在卢浮宫的彩色玻璃窗后，而线索就写在玻璃窗上的血迹中。尽管《蒙娜丽莎》实际上在《达芬奇密码》的情节中并没有占据非常突出的地位。
code. When they came to make a film and they wanted a poster, it's the Mona Lisa that is on the poster. Of course. And obviously, the reason for why the Mona Lisa is on the film poster is because it's the world's most famous painting. And one of the reasons that it's the world's most famous painting is precisely because it seems so full of mystery, a painting suited to a film about kind of codes and ancient mysteries. So two obvious questions then. So first of all, is it only famous because of the mystery rather than because of any other quality? And secondly, what actually behind all the stuff about the mystery and the murk and the smokiness, what actually do we know about it?
当他们制作电影并需要海报时，海报上印的就是《蒙娜丽莎》。当然。显然，《蒙娜丽莎》出现在电影海报上的原因，是因为它是世界上最著名的画作。而它之所以成为世界上最著名的画作，原因之一恰恰是因为它看起来充满了神秘感，这幅画非常适合一部关于密码和古老谜团的电影。那么有两个显而易见的问题。首先，它仅仅是因为神秘感而出名，而不是因为其他任何品质吗？其次，抛开所有关于神秘、阴暗和烟雾缭绕的说法，我们到底对它了解多少？
So let's take the first one. Is it so famous purely because of this sort of the questions rather than because of any innate quality? I mean, I think that is the big question. And let's come to that later. So we'll kind of explore what it is that has made the Mona Lisa as famous. as it is. And I think it's really interesting because it tells us a lot about the history of how conceptions of culture have evolved over the centuries, and particularly perhaps in the in the in the 20th century. Your second question. Yeah. I mean, let's assume the
让我们先回答第一个问题。它之所以如此出名，纯粹是因为这些疑问，而不是因为任何内在的品质吗？我的意思是，我认为这是一个大问题。我们稍后再谈。我们将探讨是什么让《蒙娜丽莎》变得如此出名。我认为这非常有趣，因为它告诉了我们很多关于文化观念在几个世纪以来，特别是20世纪以来是如何演变的。你的第二个问题。是的，我的意思是，假设
Mona Lisa isn't a portrait of a vampire. Then, then who is it a portrait of? When was the painting begun? When was it finished? I mean, was it ever finished? And these are all kind of pretty basic questions that have been furiously debated for centuries and centuries and centuries. But not unusual questions. No, Tom. Not unusual questions. I mean, these are the questions that people ask about all kinds of Renaissance paintings, don't they? Absolutely. You know, who painted it, why, when, where, who's the sitter, all of that kind of thing. Yeah. And I think that the intensity of the controversy that seems to lie around these questions when it comes to the Mona Lisa is actually just another marker of how incredibly famous it is. Because every art historian, everybody who
《蒙娜丽莎》不是吸血鬼的肖像。那么，她到底是谁的肖像？这幅画是什么时候开始画的？什么时候完成的？我的意思是，它完成过吗？这些都是几个世纪以来一直被激烈争论的基本问题。但这些问题并不罕见。不，汤姆。这些问题并不罕见。我的意思是，这些是人们对各种文艺复兴时期画作都会问的问题，不是吗？绝对是。你知道，谁画的、为什么画、什么时候画、在哪里画、模特是谁，诸如此类。是的。我认为围绕《蒙娜丽莎》的这些问题所产生的争议强度，实际上只是它极其出名的一个标志。因为每一位艺术史学家，每一个
who aspires to be an art historian, knows that if you come up with a new theory about the Mona Lisa, you'll immediately get it into the newspapers. So there's a kind of incentive there to come up often with quite mad theories. Yeah. However, there is one thing that we absolutely do know about the painting, and that, of course, is the identity of the person who painted it, and even Dan Brown gets that right,
立志成为艺术史学家的人都知道，如果你提出了关于《蒙娜丽莎》的新理论，你立刻就能上报纸。所以，提出一些往往相当疯狂的理论是有动机的。然而，关于这幅画，有一件事是我们绝对知道的，那就是画家的身份，甚至连丹·布朗也搞对了，
because it's there in the title of his book. It's Leonardo. Although he gets the name wrong. It does. He gets the name wrong because Leonardo da Vinci, Da Vinci, I mean, I can't believe there are any listeners who don't know this. Da Vinci is not his surname. Da Vinci just means from Vinci, which is where he was born.
因为在他的书名里就写着。是列奥纳多。尽管他把名字搞错了。确实。他把名字搞错了，因为列奥纳多·达·芬奇，“达·芬奇”，我的意思是，我无法相信还有听众不知道这一点。达·芬奇不是他的姓氏。达·芬奇只是意味着“来自芬奇”，那是他出生的地方。
Like if Dan Brown wrote a book about you and he called it the From Salisbury Code. Yeah, exactly. So Leonardo da Vinci, we know that he paints it. And he, of course, is one of the great figures of European culture, and extraordinary man, I think, entirely deserving of his own series on the rest of history in due course. But for now, let's zoom in on one particular moment in that extraordinary life of his. And it is April 1500. And we are in Florence, which is Leonardo's native city. This is almost certainly where he'd been born 48 years before. And he is the illegitimate son of a Florentine notary,
就像如果丹·布朗写了一本关于你的书，把它叫做《索尔兹伯里密码》。是的，完全正确。所以列奥纳多·达·芬奇，我们知道是他画的。他当然是欧洲文化中最伟大的人物之一，一个非凡的人，我认为他完全值得在“历史的其余部分”节目中拥有自己的系列节目。但现在，让我们聚焦于他非凡一生中的一个特定时刻。那是1500年4月。我们身处佛罗伦萨，这是列奥纳多的故乡。这几乎肯定是他48年前出生的地方。他是佛罗伦萨公证人
Sir Piero da Vinci, who came from the small town of Vinci, which is about 20 miles west of Florence. hence the name. And Leonardo, right from the beginning, everyone recognizes that he is an astonishing talent. So he gets apprenticed very early to a famous Florentine artist, works in his workshop. He qualifies as a master. And he is recognized even in Florence, which is a city, I mean, it's the archetype of a great center of culture, Renaissance Florence. As a man of really stupefying, talent and what strikes people as stupefying about him isn't necessarily his talent as an artist. I think he is rated slightly below his younger contemporaries Michelangelo and Raphael on that score, but the sheer range of his interests. So he's a complete polymath. He's not just a painter.
皮耶罗·达·芬奇的私生子，他来自芬奇小镇，距离佛罗伦萨以西约20英里。因此得名。列奥纳多从一开始就被公认为拥有惊人的天赋。所以他很早就被送去给一位著名的佛罗伦萨艺术家当学徒，并在他的工作室工作。他获得了大师资格。即使在佛罗伦萨——这个作为伟大文化中心原型的文艺复兴城市——他也被公认为是一个拥有令人震惊的天赋的人。而人们觉得他令人震惊的并不一定是他的艺术天赋。我认为他在那方面的评价略低于他年轻的同代人米开朗基罗和拉斐尔，而是他兴趣的广度。所以他是一个全才。他不仅仅是一位画家。
He's also a would-be engineer. He's a natural philosopher. There is no limit to the things that he's interested in. And this, of course, makes him an object of great interest to the cultural elites in Florence at the time, which Dominic, we've done a series on, and this is the Medici, and specifically Lorenzo, the magnificent, the guy who serves in the popular imagination as the archetype of the Florentine patrons of great art. Lorenzo took him up, didn't he, and used him as, among other things, as a kind of ambassador, but also as a kind of gift. So he sends him to Ludovico Schwarzse,
他也是一位准工程师。他是一位自然哲学家。他感兴趣的事物没有限制。当然，这使他成为当时佛罗伦萨文化精英们非常感兴趣的对象，也就是多米尼克，我们做过一个系列节目的美第奇家族，特别是“伟大的洛伦佐”，那个在流行文化想象中作为佛罗伦萨伟大艺术赞助人原型的人。洛伦佐看重他，不是吗？并把他用作大使，同时也作为一种礼物。所以他把他送给了卢多维科·斯福尔扎，
who's the Duke of Milan, Florence's relations with Milan, enormously important in this period. And Schwarzer, who's a patron of the arts himself, is very taken with Leonardo, doesn't it? And Leonardo basically ends up working for Schwarzer for about almost 20 years, 18 years. Yeah, 18 years in all. So by 1500, Leonardo, who's returning from Milan via Venice to Florence,
也就是米兰公爵。佛罗伦萨与米兰的关系在这一时期非常重要。而斯福尔扎本人也是一位艺术赞助人，他非常看重列奥纳多，不是吗？列奥纳多基本上在斯福尔扎手下工作了近20年，18年。是的，总共18年。所以到了1500年，列奥纳多经由威尼斯从米兰返回佛罗伦萨，
He's done pretty well for himself in Milan. So he's famous as a great painter. He's done this mural, The Last Supper, very important in the Da Vinci Code, very important also in the history of Western art. And two very innovative portraits of women. And one of these portrays Ludovico Sforza's young mistress, Chichilia Galarani. And she is shown rather coyly kind of fondling and ermine. Yeah. And Tabby's favourite picture, I think.
他在米兰干得相当不错。所以他作为一位伟大的画家而闻名。他完成了这幅壁画《最后的晚餐》，这在《达芬奇密码》中非常重要，在西方艺术史上也非常重要。还有两幅非常有创意的女性肖像。其中一幅描绘了卢多维科·斯福尔扎年轻的情妇切奇莉亚·加莱拉尼。她被描绘得相当羞涩，怀里抱着一只白鼬。是的。我想这是塔比最喜欢的画。
I think so, yeah. She loves fondling and ermine. But the other thing about Leonardo is that he's got a utilitarian value as well as an aesthetic one, hasn't he? Because he's also designing all kinds of, I mean, obviously he's designing all his mad stuff like parachutes and helicopters. Tanks. But he's designing kind of hydraulics projects and stuff and city works and all these kinds of things. And fortifications and defenses and things like this. I mean, your claim about him being a problem.
我想是的。她喜欢抱着白鼬。但列奥纳多的另一件事是，他不仅具有审美价值，还具有实用价值，不是吗？因为他还在设计各种东西，我的意思是，显然他正在设计他那些疯狂的东西，比如降落伞和直升机。坦克。但他还在设计各种水利工程、城市工程以及所有这些东西。还有防御工事和防御设施之类的。我的意思是，你关于他是全才的说法被这一切充分证实了。我了解到那些疯狂的东西，比如坦克和直升机，
Polymath is well borne out by all this. I gather the kind of the mad stuff, so the tanks and the helicopters. It's unlikely any of them would have worked even had the technology been available to make them work. But the fortifications and the canals and everything, absolutely. And that essentially is why Switzer loved him. I mean, the ability to paint his mistress fondling and ermine was a kind of an advantage. But it's the engineering that really makes Leonardo's fortune. and he returns to Florence pretty well off.
即使有技术支持，它们也不太可能成功。但防御工事、运河以及其他一切，绝对是可行的。而这本质上就是斯福尔扎喜欢他的原因。我的意思是，能够画出他怀抱白鼬的情妇是一种优势。但正是工程学真正成就了列奥纳多的财富。他回到佛罗伦萨时相当富有。
So he's four months before he arrives in Florence. He sends a very large sum of money, about 600 ducats, to a Florentine bank. So he'll have something there waiting for him when he returns to Florence. And just to give people a sense of how much that is, 20 ducats will rent you a very nice house in the central Florence for a year. So Leonardo, you know, he's done well for himself. But what did you say? this was 1500. So 1500, by the time he comes back, Florence's golden age has passed. They've been through the whole business with the bonfire, the vanities and southern Arola. The
在他抵达佛罗伦萨的四个月前，他向一家佛罗伦萨银行汇了一大笔钱，大约600杜卡特。这样当他回到佛罗伦萨时，就会有一笔钱等着他。为了让大家了解这笔钱有多少，20杜卡特就能在佛罗伦萨市中心租一栋非常好的房子住一年。所以列奥纳多，你知道，他干得不错。但你刚才说这是1500年。所以1500年，当他回来时，佛罗伦萨的黄金时代已经过去了。他们经历了萨沃纳罗拉的“虚荣之火”事件。
Medici have actually been kicked out of Florence, haven't they? And Florence is a republic again. And the biggest development, you know, one of the great developments in medieval Italian or early modern Italian history, the French invasion of 1494 has thrown Italy into total tumult. Schwarz has been kicked out in Milan. The French have been rampaging through the Italian Peninsula and they are the big power brokers now. And basically Leonardo, that leaves Leonardo a bit adrift, doesn't it? He needs a new patron because he doesn't have the menacee, he doesn't have Schwarzse. Yeah. So that's why he's left Milan is, as you say, Schwarzis been kicked out. But the problem is that even though he's a very big name, I mean, he's famous across Italy, he does also
美第奇家族实际上已经被赶出了佛罗伦萨，不是吗？佛罗伦萨又变成了一个共和国。而最大的发展，你知道，中世纪意大利或近代早期意大利历史上最伟大的发展之一，1494年的法国入侵使意大利陷入了彻底的混乱。斯福尔扎在米兰被赶下台。法国人在意大利半岛横行霸道，他们现在是主要的权力掮客。基本上，这让列奥纳多有点漂泊不定，不是吗？他需要一位新的赞助人，因为他没有美第奇家族，也没有斯福尔扎。是的。所以这就是他离开米兰的原因，正如你所说，斯福尔扎被赶走了。但问题是，尽管他名气很大，我的意思是，他在意大利各地都很出名，但他确实也
bring a certain amount of baggage with him. So in particular, he has a reputation for never finishing projects. So, George Vasari, who will write the first biography of Leonardo, famously says of Leonardo that he started many things and never finished them. And the most notorious example of this had happened in Milan, which was a massive equestrian monument to the father of Ludovico Sforza, that ends up being aborted when the French invade Italy, because the Milanese need the bronze that was going to be used for the mould, they need to turn it into artillery to try and stop the French, it doesn't work. And when the French Occupy Milan, they shoot up the great clay model of this equestrian statue that Leonardo had made. So there's
带了一些包袱。特别是，他有从不完成项目的名声。所以，乔尔乔·瓦萨里，他将撰写第一部列奥纳多传记，他曾著名地评价列奥纳多说，他开始了很多事情，却从未完成它们。最臭名昭著的例子发生在米兰，那是一座为卢多维科·斯福尔扎的父亲建造的巨大骑马纪念碑，当法国入侵意大利时，该项目被迫中止，因为米兰人需要原本用于铸模的青铜，他们需要将其制成大炮来试图阻止法国人，但这没用。当法国人占领米兰时，他们射击了列奥纳多制作的这座骑马雕像的巨大粘土模型。所以
nothing left of it. And this casts a slight shadow over his reputation. So there's a story that when Michelangelo, who is younger than Leonardo and should properly be showing him respect, when Michelangelo meets Leonardo, he scoffs at him and says that the casting of the bronze had been beyond Leonardo's technological abilities. And I think that this is a kind of a reproach that he has to bear, however unfairly. There's also the problem that he hasn't actually done that many paintings while he was in Florence. And the most famous painting, The Last Supper, I mean, this isn't readily accessible for anyone from Florence.
什么都没剩下。这给他的名声蒙上了一层阴影。所以有一个故事说，当米开朗基罗——他比列奥纳多年轻，本应表现出尊重——见到列奥纳多时，他嘲笑他，说青铜铸造超出了列奥纳多的技术能力。我认为这是一种他不得不承受的指责，尽管这很不公平。还有一个问题是，他在佛罗伦萨期间实际上并没有画多少画。而最著名的画作《最后的晚餐》，我的意思是，这对佛罗伦萨的任何人来说都不容易看到。
And it's probably already starting to fade because Leonardo's exceptional. experimented with mad kinds of paints. So he is actively looking for commissions and not just to make money, but also I think as a way of advertising what he can do as an artist, because every painting will be able to serve him as a kind of calling card. And so the first two years that he's back in Florence, we know from his records that he is taking on a lot of work. He's doing a taking a lot of commissions. These commissions do not include the Mona Lisa because, as I say, we have detail records, the Mona Lisa isn't mentioned in them. And in fact, it is a part of the mystery of the painting that the Mona Lisa isn't mentioned in any of Leonardo's surviving drawings,
而且它可能已经开始褪色了，因为列奥纳多尝试了疯狂的颜料。所以他正在积极寻找委托，不仅是为了赚钱，而且我认为也是为了宣传他作为艺术家的能力，因为每一幅画都能成为他的名片。所以他回到佛罗伦萨的前两年，我们从他的记录中知道他承担了很多工作。他接了很多委托。这些委托不包括《蒙娜丽莎》，因为正如我所说，我们有详细的记录，记录中没有提到《蒙娜丽莎》。事实上，这幅画的神秘之处在于，《蒙娜丽莎》没有出现在列奥纳多的任何现存素描中，
any of his surviving notebooks. So that, you know, that adds a certain quality of mystery to it. So he goes on. He works, I mean, unbelievably, one day we'll do a series on the Borgias. And he works for Cheslery Borgia, doesn't he, as chief engineer. So making tanks and helicopters for the Borgias. Yeah. So that's in 5002 through to the early months of 1503. And then 1503, the spring of 1503, he is back in Florence. Some critics and biographers think this is the point when he did the Mona Lisa. Others like Kenneth Clark, who did the Great Civilization BBC series at the end of the 60s. He thought it might have been a year later, 1504.
也没有出现在他的任何现存笔记本中。所以，这为它增添了一种神秘感。所以他继续工作。我的意思是，难以置信，有一天我们会做一个关于波吉亚家族的系列节目。他曾为切萨雷·波吉亚工作，不是吗？担任首席工程师。所以为波吉亚家族制造坦克和直升机。是的。那是1502年到1503年初。然后是1503年，1503年春天，他回到了佛罗伦萨。一些评论家和传记作者认为这是他创作《蒙娜丽莎》的时间点。其他人，比如肯尼斯·克拉克，他在60年代末制作了伟大的BBC系列节目《文明》，他认为可能是晚了一年，1504年。
So let's say 1503, 1504, or possibly even a later date. That's when he does the Mona Lisa. Yeah, so this is a debate. that again has been running and running and running. So it's 1503 to perhaps 1511, 1512. This is the kind of the range of dates. But the bigger question, which I suppose is allied to that, is who is the person in the picture?
所以我们说是1503年、1504年，甚至可能是更晚的日期。那是他创作《蒙娜丽莎》的时间。是的，所以这是一个争论，一直在持续。所以是从1503年到可能1511年、1512年。这是日期范围。但更大的问题，我想与此相关的是，画中的人是谁？
And I mean, the name Mona Lisa, it's later. I mean, it becomes popularized in the 19th century, but it's first coined in what, the 1540s by Georgie Oversary, who you've already mentioned in his great book, The Lives of the Artists, the great biographer of Renaissance Italy. Yeah, so kind of 160 portrait sketches of the artists of the age. Bissari's great hero is Michelangelo, but he does give Leonardo a decent write-up.
我的意思是，“蒙娜丽莎”这个名字是后来的。我的意思是，它在19世纪变得流行起来，但它最早是在1540年代由乔尔乔·瓦萨里创造的，你已经提到过他，他写了那本伟大的书《艺苑名人传》，他是文艺复兴时期意大利伟大的传记作家。是的，大约160位艺术家的肖像素描。瓦萨里的伟大英雄是米开朗基罗，但他确实给了列奥纳多不错的评价。
And so if we estimate that the amount of space that Bessari gives to an artist is a reflection of how much he esteems the artist, then Michelangelo's number one, then Raphael, then Jotto, much earlier painter, of course. And then Leonardo. So Leonardo is number four. Pretty good podium. I mean, one of them is not getting a medal. Leonardo not quite podiuming there, is he? He's just missed bronze. Yeah. So this is what Fassari has to say. He mentions the Mona Lisa explicitly. He writes, Leonardo undertook to paint the portrait of the wife of Francesco del Giacondo, Mona Lisa. So, I mean, there's one thing. It's not the Mona Lisa. It's the Mona Lisa properly.
所以如果我们估计瓦萨里给一位艺术家的篇幅反映了他对这位艺术家的推崇程度，那么米开朗基罗是第一，然后是拉斐尔，然后是乔托，当然是一位更早期的画家。然后是列奥纳多。所以列奥纳多排在第四。相当不错的领奖台。我的意思是，其中一个人没拿到奖牌。列奥纳多没能登上领奖台，不是吗？他刚好错过了铜牌。是的。所以瓦萨里是这样说的。他明确提到了《蒙娜丽莎》。他写道：“列奥纳多承接了弗朗切斯科·德尔·焦孔多的妻子蒙娜丽莎的肖像画。”所以，我的意思是，有一件事。它不是“蒙娜丽莎”（Mona Lisa），而是“蒙娜丽莎”（Monna Lisa）。
but it gives us the name. And Mona Lisa is Ma, Donna Lisa, so my lady Lisa. But that sentence also gives us the name that is used in Italy and in France. So in Italy it's La Gioconda. In France, it's La Jaconde. And there's a pun there. So it's the feminine form of Lisa's husband's name. So essentially, it's kind of Mrs. Giacondo, La Giaconda.
但这给了我们名字。而“蒙娜丽莎”是“Ma Donna Lisa”，即“我的丽莎夫人”。但那句话也给了我们在意大利和法国使用的名字。所以在意大利是“La Gioconda”。在法国是“La Joconde”。这里有一个双关语。它是丽莎丈夫姓氏的阴性形式。所以本质上，它是“焦孔多夫人”，La Gioconda。
But Giaconda and Giacond, they mean in Italian and Frenchond. French respectively, kind of happy, cheerful, joyous. And Vasari implies in his life of Leonardo that Leonardo leaned into this pun and that Mona Lisa's smile was key to his vision of the painting right from the very start. So Vasari writes, while he was painting Mona Lisa, who was a very beautiful woman, he had her constantly entertained by singers, musicians and gestures so that she would be merry and not look melancholic as portraits often do. As a result, in this painting of Leonardo's, there was a smile,
但“Gioconda”和“Joconde”在意大利语和法语中分别意味着“快乐的、愉快的、喜悦的”。瓦萨里在他的列奥纳多传记中暗示，列奥纳多利用了这个双关语，蒙娜丽莎的微笑从一开始就是他创作这幅画愿景的关键。所以瓦萨里写道：“当他为蒙娜丽莎画像时，她是一位非常美丽的女性，他让她一直由歌手、音乐家和弄臣陪伴，这样她就会快乐，而不会像肖像画中常见的那样显得忧郁。结果，在列奥纳多的这幅画中，出现了一个微笑，
so enchanting that it was more divine than human. And those who saw it marveled to find it so similar to that of the living original. I mean, I think, again, that's attributing the smile with more jollity than the painting deserves. Anyway, that anecdote may not even be true, right? Possibly, but possibly not, because when Vasari wrote up that anecdote, he was living in Florence, just a short distance from the Giacondo family home at a time when Mona Lisa was still alive. So it is perfectly possible that he got that directly from La Giaconda's mouth. I mean, we can't know, but it's possible, I would say.
迷人得超出了人类的范畴。那些看到它的人惊叹于它与活生生的原型如此相似。”我的意思是，我认为，这再次将微笑归因于比画作本身应得的更多的快乐。无论如何，那个轶事甚至可能不是真的，对吧？可能，但也可能不是，因为当瓦萨里写下那个轶事时，他住在佛罗伦萨，距离焦孔多家族的家只有很短的距离，当时蒙娜丽莎还活着。所以他完全有可能直接从焦孔多夫人的口中得知这一点。我的意思是，我们无法确定，但我会说这是可能的。
So who is she? Who's a husband? What's going on there? I mean, he's literally called Mr. Happy, but. Isn't he? Well, as well, he should be because Francesco del Giacondo is doing very well for himself. So he's very ambitious. He's very upwardly mobile and he's becoming incredibly rich.
那么她是谁？她丈夫是谁？发生了什么？我的意思是，他简直被称为“快乐先生”，但是，不是吗？嗯，他理应如此，因为弗朗切斯科·德尔·焦孔多干得非常出色。所以他非常有野心。他非常有向上流动的动力，而且他变得极其富有。
of humble background, his grandfather had begun as an artisan in the barrel-making business, and he ends up running an entire barrel-making empire. Then Francesco's father had moved on from the barrel-making into textiles, which is the obvious place that you go for kind of high-end products, much more money to be made. And Geocondo himself then expands into silks, into money-lending, and into sugar. So this is the early days of the Atlantic sugar economy. Yeah, yeah.
出身卑微，他的祖父最初是木桶生意中的一名工匠，最终经营着一个庞大的木桶帝国。然后弗朗切斯科的父亲从木桶生意转向了纺织业，这是你从事高端产品生产的必然选择，能赚更多的钱。然后焦孔多本人又扩展到丝绸、借贷和糖业。所以这是大西洋糖业经济的早期阶段。是的，是的。
And it has been thought that perhaps Mona Lisa had access to lots of sugar and her teeth rotted. And this is why she's not showing her teeth. And that's one of the clues to the mystery of the smile. That's really trying too hard. But this is a very familiar Florentine journey. You start like the medit you did. You make money in one thing.
人们认为蒙娜丽莎可能接触过大量的糖，导致她的牙齿腐烂了。这就是她不露齿的原因。这是微笑之谜的线索之一。那真是太牵强了。但这是一种非常熟悉的佛罗伦萨式旅程。你像美第奇家族那样开始。你通过一种生意赚钱。
Then you move into, I mean, textiles wool is what Florentine. money is based on and then you move into banking or money lending or whatever and you diversify. So what Francesco was doing is absolutely standard. And then he does the standard thing, which is that he invests a lot of his money into land, doesn't he? So especially now that the war is broken out with the French and Italy is absolutely being ravaged and ripped apart. It makes sense to invest in property and in land because that is the safest possible bet. And of course, what you also do, and this is a timeless story, I mean, we see it so much in English history as well, is that if you are socially mobile from a humble background, you invest in
然后你转向，我的意思是，羊毛纺织是佛罗伦萨金钱的基础，然后你转向银行业或借贷业等等，你进行多元化经营。所以弗朗切斯科所做的是绝对标准的。然后他做了标准的事情，那就是他把大量的钱投资在土地上，不是吗？所以特别是现在战争已经与法国爆发，意大利绝对被蹂躏和撕裂。投资房地产和土地是有意义的，因为那是尽可能最稳妥的赌注。当然，你还会做的一件事——这是一个永恒的故事，我的意思是，我们在英国历史上也看到了很多——如果你出身卑微但社会地位在上升，你就会投资于
an upper-class wife. And this is what Francesco does by marrying Lisa Gerardini, because Lisa Gerardini is from an ancient Tuscan family that ranked as one of the original founders of the Florentine Republic. So a tremendous aristocratic pedigree. It is obviously a bit of embarrassing for Lisa that she has to marry the grandson of a barrel maker. But her father is is not a good businessman. He's running short of money. He needs money. And so he essentially sells Lisa to Francesco. And it's a good marriage. So Lisa is 15 when she marries Francesco. Francesco is 30. And she is his second wife. And as we've heard, we'll end up outliving him. And I think that although the context for the marriage is a mercenary one, it seems to have been a relatively successful
一位上流社会的妻子。这就是弗朗切斯科通过娶丽莎·盖拉尔迪尼所做的，因为丽莎·盖拉尔迪尼来自一个古老的托斯卡纳家族，该家族被列为佛罗伦萨共和国的原始创始人之一。所以有着惊人的贵族血统。丽莎不得不嫁给一个木桶匠的孙子，这显然有点尴尬。但她的父亲不是一个好的商人。他缺钱。他需要钱。所以他本质上把丽莎卖给了弗朗切斯科。这是一桩不错的婚姻。所以丽莎嫁给弗朗切斯科时是15岁。弗朗切斯科是30岁。她是他的第二任妻子。正如我们所听到的，她最终比他活得更久。我认为虽然婚姻的背景是功利的，但它似乎是一桩相对成功的
marriage. So Francesco keeps his side of the bargain by becoming fabulously rich, and Lisa sticks to hers by having lots of children. And she has six in all. Four of them survive infancy. And she also brings up a son of Francesco's by his first wife. And again, their relationship seems to have been very good. All the evidence points to the fact that she was a very kind and supportive stepmother. There is one scandal which erupts in 1512, and it's focused on Lisa's daughter, Camilla, who the year before so in 1511, had become a nun at the age of 12. So, I mean, it's quite early.
婚姻。所以弗朗切斯科通过变得极其富有履行了他的职责，而丽莎通过生了很多孩子履行了她的职责。她总共生了六个。其中四个活过了婴儿期。她还抚养了弗朗切斯科与第一任妻子所生的儿子。同样，他们的关系似乎非常好。所有证据都表明她是一位非常善良和支持继子的继母。1512年爆发了一起丑闻，焦点是丽莎的女儿卡米拉，她在前一年，也就是1511年，在12岁时成为了一名修女。所以，我的意思是，这相当早。
But it's a way essentially of avoiding having to pay a dowry for her. So you either marry her off or you park her in a nunry. And that's what they do with Camilla. and in 1512, four men, including madly, a brother of the Cardinal of Pavia, are reported to have climbed up a ladder into the convent where Camilla was installed. And two nuns, it is said, were waiting for them. And the intruders, I quote, touched the breasts of the said nuns. And there was apparently lots of fondling and groping. And Camilla is said to have been one of these two nuns.
但这本质上是一种避免为她支付嫁妆的方法。所以你要么把她嫁出去，要么把她关进修道院。这就是他们对卡米拉所做的。而在1512年，四名男子，包括疯狂的帕维亚红衣主教的兄弟，据报道爬上梯子进入了卡米拉所在的修道院。据说有两名修女在等着他们。入侵者，我引用，“触摸了上述修女的乳房”。显然有很多抚摸和猥亵。据说卡米拉就是这两名修女之一。
and the four men were found guilty, but the two nuns were absolved. So a whiff of scandal, but perhaps no more than that. Yeah. But apart from that, Lisa's life is pretty uneventful, isn't it? So, as you said, Francesco, 15 years are senior. He dies in 1537. And in his will, he says she is his beloved, noble spirit, a faithful wife. She lives to a pretty good age for the time, 70, shows she dies about 12 or 13 years later.
那四名男子被判有罪，但两名修女被宣告无罪。所以这确实有一丝丑闻的味道，但或许仅此而已。是的。但除此之外，丽莎的生活相当平淡，不是吗？正如你所说，弗朗切斯科比她大15岁。他于1537年去世。在遗嘱中，他称她为他挚爱的、高贵的灵魂，一位忠诚的妻子。她活到了当时相当高寿的70岁，这意味着她在约12或13年后去世。
We don't know exactly when. and that's all we know. That's all we know of this character. Which is amazing because if she is the person in the Mona Lisa, then her face has a claim to be the most famous face of anyone who's lived in the whole of history, which is a kind of jaw-dropping thought. Wow. Yeah.
我们不知道具体时间。这就是我们所知道的一切。这就是我们对这个人物的全部了解。这令人惊叹，因为如果她就是《蒙娜丽莎》画中的人，那么她的脸就有资格成为历史上最著名的一张脸，这真是一个令人瞠目结舌的想法。哇。是的。
But is she the woman? Because there are some critics who say this is not the woman. She may not have existed at all. This may be a fictional person. This may be a kind of just a generic, embodiment of a female beauty or of, you know, a feminine elegance and grace or whatever. Because, for example, there is no record of Leonardo having been paid by anybody for this painting, right? And if he had done it for a rich patron, you would assume he would have been paid and he would have
但她真的是那个女人吗？因为有些评论家说这根本不是那个女人。她可能根本就不存在。这可能是一个虚构的人物。这可能只是女性美的一种泛指，或者是一种女性优雅和风度的化身，等等。因为，例如，没有记录显示列奥纳多曾因这幅画收到过任何人的报酬，对吧？如果他是为一位富有的赞助人创作的，你会认为他应该会收到报酬，而且他会
kept the receipt. Yeah. And he seems to have kept the painting with him until he died. We've got that landscape, which is not a realistic landscape. It's not a landscape that anyone can identify. So is this fantastical background painted in that way because it's appropriate to a woman who also is invented? And we do know from his notebooks that Leonardo was very interested in the kind of the notion of their being ideal beauty. Is the Mona Lisa not a real person at all? But what if she's a real person? I think that certainly for the past 200 years, there's been a feeling that the Mona Lisa, is a bit boring.
保留收据。是的。而且他似乎一直把这幅画带在身边，直到去世。我们看到了那幅风景，那不是写实的风景。那不是任何人都能辨认出的风景。那么，这个梦幻般的背景之所以这样画，是因为它适合一个同样是虚构出来的女人吗？我们确实从他的笔记中知道，列奥纳多对理想美的概念非常感兴趣。难道《蒙娜丽莎》根本就不是一个真实的人吗？但如果她是一个真实的人呢？我认为在过去200年里，人们确实有一种感觉，觉得《蒙娜丽莎》有点无聊。
I mean, she's just the wife of an Italian businessman. Couldn't she be someone slightly more interesting? So there have been various candidates. So one of them is a woman called Pacifica Brandano, and she was the mistress of the son of Lorenzo the beneficent, a guy called Giuliano de Medici. And he ends up returning to Florence, reestablishing Medici rule,
我的意思是，她只是一个意大利商人的妻子。她难道不能是一个稍微有趣一点的人吗？所以出现了各种候选人。其中之一是一位名叫帕西菲卡·布兰达诺（Pacifica Brandano）的女性，她是“伟大的洛伦佐”之子朱利亚诺·德·美第奇（Giuliano de Medici）的情妇。他最终回到了佛罗伦萨，重建了美第奇家族的统治，
and he's essentially the kind of the autocrat of Florence, between 1513 and 1516. Why does anyone think that the Mona Lisa might be this woman, Pacifica Brandano? There's actually quite a good reason. It's because the only person that we know of who saw the Mona Lisa in the lifetime of Leonardo and described it in writing, he claimed that the painting had been commissioned by Giuliano. And if so, then wouldn't it be his mistress? Then there's another much more famous woman who is identified with the Mona Lisa, and this is Isabella Desti, who was the marquise of Mantua, and she's the most famous, the most celebrated female patron of the arts in the Renaissance. And again, there are reasons for thinking that it might be her. So she was always imploring Leonardo to paint her portrait. Leonardo actually went to Mantua and made sketches of her. We've said that the backdrop to the Monaco,
他在1513年至1516年间基本上是佛罗伦萨的独裁者。为什么有人认为《蒙娜丽莎》可能是这个女人帕西菲卡·布兰达诺呢？其实有一个很好的理由。因为在列奥纳多生前见过《蒙娜丽莎》并以文字描述过它的唯一已知人物，声称这幅画是由朱利亚诺委托创作的。如果是这样，那不就是他的情妇吗？然后还有另一位更著名的女性被认为是《蒙娜丽莎》，那就是曼托瓦侯爵夫人伊莎贝拉·德斯蒂（Isabella d'Este），她是文艺复兴时期最著名、最受赞誉的女性艺术赞助人。同样，也有理由认为可能是她。因为她一直恳求列奥纳多为她画像。列奥纳多确实去过曼托瓦并为她画过素描。我们说过《蒙娜丽莎》的背景，
Lisa, the landscape is fantastical. Assuming that it isn't, assuming that it is actually a portrait of somewhere in Italy, it might be the Dolomites. I mean, it's much more likely to be the Dolomites than Tuscany. And Mantua is quite near the Dolomites. And also in the painting, she's seated on a chair with an armrest, and the armrest apparently is often used to symbolize a ruler. I think the way that you're narrating that suggests to me that you absolutely do not believe it. I mean, it doesn't look like the dolomites at all. I think that there is a slight quality of people not wanting to believe that Shakespeare wrote Shakespeare's plays. And it would be much more fun if it was the Earl of Oxford or Christopher Marlowe or someone.
那幅风景是梦幻般的。假设它不是，假设它实际上是意大利某个地方的肖像，那可能是多洛米蒂山脉。我的意思是，它更有可能是多洛米蒂山脉而不是托斯卡纳。而且曼托瓦离多洛米蒂山脉很近。此外，在画中，她坐在一把有扶手的椅子上，扶手显然经常被用来象征统治者。我觉得你叙述的方式让我觉得你绝对不相信这一点。我的意思是，它看起来一点也不像多洛米蒂山脉。我认为这有点像人们不愿相信莎士比亚写了莎士比亚的剧作。如果作者是牛津伯爵或克里斯托弗·马洛之类的人，那会更有趣。
That is exactly what I thought when you started to down this line. I thought this is exactly what it is. People just do not want a humdrum explanation. And they're groping desperately for something exotic. Okay, well, let's continue with some slightly more exotic ones. So, Sigmund Freud, guess who he thinks about Lisa is. Amaze me and tell me that it's not his mother. It is his mother.
这正是我在你开始沿着这条思路走时所想的。我想这正是它的本质。人们只是不想要一个平淡无奇的解释。他们正绝望地摸索着一些异国情调的东西。好吧，让我们继续讨论一些稍微更具异国情调的理论。那么，西格蒙德·弗洛伊德，猜猜他认为丽莎是谁。让我大吃一惊，告诉我那不是他母亲。正是他母亲。
So Freud suggested that the smile, this famous smile, was inspired by Leonardo's childhood memories of his mother's smile. Sometimes a smile is just a smile, Sigmund. Yeah, sometimes. Another very popular theory recently is that it's this guy, Sallai, who was Leonardo's apprentice, his friend, worked in his workshop. and was almost certainly his lover. Hold on. Salai's a bloke. Salai's a bloke. Yeah.
所以弗洛伊德认为，那个微笑，那个著名的微笑，灵感来自于列奥纳多童年时期对他母亲微笑的记忆。有时候微笑就只是微笑，西格蒙德。是的，有时候是这样。最近另一个非常流行的理论是，画中人是这个叫萨莱（Salai）的家伙，他是列奥纳多的学徒、朋友，在工作室工作，而且几乎可以肯定是他的情人。等等。萨莱是个男的。萨莱是个男的。是的。
Okay, this is a stretch. So Salai is, you know, he serves Leonardo as a model for his painting of John the Baptist, which is in the Louvre, together with the Mona Lisa. He provides the model for a sketch of an angel. And the idea that the Mona Lisa might be another portrait of Salai was proposed 15 years ago by an Italian art historian called Silvano Vincetti. The reason that he advances
好吧，这太牵强了。萨莱，你知道，他担任了列奥纳多《施洗者圣约翰》画作的模特，这幅画和《蒙娜丽莎》一起收藏在卢浮宫。他为一幅天使的素描提供了模特。而《蒙娜丽莎》可能是萨莱的另一幅肖像的观点，是15年前由一位名叫西尔瓦诺·文切蒂（Silvano Vincetti）的意大利艺术史学家提出的。他提出的理由
is that Vincii says that the Mona Lisa's facial features do resemble those of Salai and you can see them if you compare it to Leonardo's painting of John the Baptist. Also, he says that you can see the letter S in Mona Lisa's eyes
是文切蒂说《蒙娜丽莎》的面部特征确实与萨莱相似，如果你将它与列奥纳多的《施洗者圣约翰》进行比较，就能看出来。此外，他说如果你非常仔细地观察，眯起眼睛，并在做这件事时倒立，你就能在蒙娜丽莎的眼睛里看到字母S。
if you look very closely and squint and stand on your head while you're doing it. Right. Yeah, good luck doing that in the Louvre. And we compared it to Shakespeare. There was a guy, wasn't there, who wanted to dig up.
好吧。是的，祝你在卢浮宫里能做到这一点。我们把它和莎士比亚进行了比较。有一个人，不是吗，他想挖出
Shakespeare's body to prove that it wasn't actually Shakespeare. And Cichetti has, he's kind of, he's very much on that groove because he wanted to go to the site where Lisa Gerardini had been buried and to dig her up and to find her skull, use it to reconstruct her features and thereby prove that she couldn't have been the sitter in the Mona Lisa. Then two final theories, just before we come to the break. One theory is the Mona Lisa is a portrait of Leonardo himself. self. And this was first suggested back in 1913 by a French painter called Maurice Valle. And he argued that the lower half of the face is female, but the upper half is Leonardo's. And in 1987, an American artist called Lillian Schwartz made a famous computer mashup of the Mona Lisa with the self-portrait of Leonardo, the kind of famous one. It's presumed to be self-portrait. We don't know for sure. But it's the one where he kind of looks like Gandalf. He's got the long white hair.
莎士比亚的尸体来证明那其实不是莎士比亚。而切蒂（Cichetti）也处于那种状态，因为他想去丽莎·格拉迪尼（Lisa Gherardini）被埋葬的地方，把她挖出来，找到她的头骨，用它来重建她的面部特征，从而证明她不可能是《蒙娜丽莎》的模特。然后是最后两个理论，就在我们休息之前。一个理论是《蒙娜丽莎》是列奥纳多本人的肖像。这最初是在1913年由一位名叫莫里斯·瓦莱（Maurice Valle）的法国画家提出的。他认为脸的下半部分是女性的，但上半部分是列奥纳多的。1987年，一位名叫莉莲·施瓦茨（Lillian Schwartz）的美国艺术家将《蒙娜丽莎》与列奥纳多的自画像（那种著名的自画像）做了一个著名的电脑合成。这被认为是自画像。我们不能确定。但那是他看起来像甘道夫的那一张。他留着长长的白发。
that, you know, they match up pretty well and can kind of see how perhaps there's a hint there of them having the same facial features. And then finally, we have a theory that's been proposed by top symbolologist Robert Langdon and he proposes
你知道，它们匹配得相当好，可以从中看出也许有一丝他们拥有相同面部特征的暗示。最后，我们有一个由顶级符号学家罗伯特·兰登（Robert Langdon）提出的理论，他提出
that the Mona Lisa is an androgynous fusion of the Egyptian god Amun, so A-M-O-N, an anagram of Mona, and the goddess Isis. aka Lisa. So Mona Lisa, it's all there.
《蒙娜丽莎》是埃及神阿蒙（Amun，Mona的变位词）和女神伊西斯（Isis，即Lisa）的雌雄同体融合。所以蒙娜丽莎，一切都在那里。
And Robert Langdon, of course, is the hero of Dan Brown's Da Vinci Code. And this is what Dan Brown has Langdon say. Gentlemen, not only does the face of Mona Lisa look androgynous, but her name is an anagram of the divine union of male and female. And that, my friends, is Da Vinci's Little Secret, Da Vinci again, and the reason for Mona Lisa's knowing smile. God, do you know who says this? Tom Hanks. Tom Hanks says it in the film, a person who's been on the rest of history and had no shame about his involvement in that film. So, are you convinced by any of those?
当然，罗伯特·兰登是丹·布朗《达芬奇密码》中的英雄。这就是丹·布朗让兰登说的话。先生们，蒙娜丽莎的脸不仅看起来是雌雄同体的，而且她的名字是男女神圣结合的变位词。而那，我的朋友们，就是达芬奇的小秘密，又是达芬奇，也是蒙娜丽莎那意味深长的微笑的原因。天哪，你知道是谁说了这些话吗？汤姆·汉克斯。汤姆·汉克斯在电影里说了这些，一个在历史长河中留名，且对自己参与那部电影毫无羞耻感的人。那么，你被其中任何一个理论说服了吗？
No, of course. I mean, I have to say, Tom, I think the way you've set it up suggests to me that it's none of these people, because you've said it with a degree of skepticism. I mean, it's definitely not that bloke who's a bloke. I think that's a definite note. And I also don't think it's half of it is Leonardo da Vinci's face. Okay. However, what is undoubtedly the case is. throughout the 20th century, it was generally accepted by art historians that absolute certainty about the identity of the Mona Lisa was impossible. So I will quote Donald Sassoon, who is the author of the definitive history of the Mona Lisa. I've drawn a lot on his book for this episode. And at the end of his book, he declares himself agnostic as to who the painting portrays, so to quote him, my conclusion is that the evidence is too scanty for us to arrive at any firm
不，当然没有。我的意思是，我不得不说，汤姆，我觉得你设定这个话题的方式让我觉得这些都不是真的，因为你带着一种怀疑的态度说了出来。我的意思是，那绝对不是那个男的。我认为那绝对是否定的。我也不认为其中一半是列奥纳多的脸。好吧。然而，毫无疑问的是，在整个20世纪，艺术史学家普遍接受关于《蒙娜丽莎》身份的绝对确定性是不可能的。所以我将引用唐纳德·萨松（Donald Sassoon）的话，他是《蒙娜丽莎》权威历史的作者。我在这一集中大量参考了他的书。在书的结尾，他宣称自己对画中人是谁持不可知论，引用他的话：“我的结论是，证据太少，我们无法得出任何确定的
identification, we shall never know, not that this will stop people from trying. And of course, he's quite right. People do continue to try. He then added this reflection. There is always the remote possibility that some new evidence will be unearthed. And do you know, Dominic, do you know listeners? He was not wrong, because four years later, after Donald Sassoon wrote that in 2005, exactly such a piece of new evidence was on earthed. And the brilliant thing about it, it conclusively proves who the woman portrayed in the Mona Lisa had been. And more than that, it specifies pretty precisely exactly when Leonardo had begun painting it. Criky, what a bombshell.
结论，我们永远不会知道，但这并不能阻止人们尝试。”当然，他是对的。人们确实在继续尝试。他随后补充了这样的反思：总有一种微小的可能性，会有一些新的证据被发掘出来。你知道吗，多米尼克，你知道吗，听众们？他没说错，因为四年后，在唐纳德·萨松于2005年写下那段话之后，确实发现了这样一件新的证据。最精彩的是，它确凿地证明了《蒙娜丽莎》画中的女人是谁。不仅如此，它还相当精确地指出了列奥纳多开始创作它的时间。天哪，真是个重磅炸弹。
Ladies and gentlemen, do not go away. we will return after the break with these stunning revelations. Welcome back everybody to the rest is history. I am waiting with bated breath to find out who the Mona Lisa really was and when the great painting was painted. Tom, you promised us an absolute bombshell. I hope you're going to deliver. Okay, so let's go to the Florentine Chancellery in October 1503
女士们，先生们，请不要走开。我们将在休息后带着这些惊人的揭秘回来。欢迎大家回到《历史的其余部分》。我正屏息以待，想知道蒙娜丽莎到底是谁，以及这幅伟大的画作是什么时候画的。汤姆，你向我们承诺了一个绝对的重磅炸弹。我希望你能兑现。好吧，让我们回到1503年10月的佛罗伦萨大法官署，
where a clerk in the Chancellery is reading an edition of, the letters of the great Roman orator Cicero. This is a guy called Agostino Vespucci. He's a very clever, very well-connected man. So he's a humanist scholar. And of course, humanist scholars, all they do at this point is read Cicero. Yeah.
那里的一名书记员正在阅读伟大的罗马演说家西塞罗的书信集。这个人叫阿戈斯蒂诺·韦斯普奇（Agostino Vespucci）。他是一个非常聪明、人脉很广的人。他是一位人文主义学者。当然，人文主义学者在当时所做的就是阅读西塞罗。是的。
He's an assistant to Niccolo Machiavelli, famous author of political treatises. And he is a professional associate of Leonardo, because he's one of the administrators who just recently have signed a contract with Leonardo to paint the great council hall in Florence with a spectacular battle scene, an illustration of a great Florentine victory. And as he's reading this book, this guy Vespucci comes across a reference in one of Cicero's
他是尼科洛·马基雅维利（Niccolo Machiavelli，著名政治论著作者）的助手。他是列奥纳多的职业伙伴，因为他是最近与列奥纳多签署合同的行政人员之一，委托他在佛罗伦萨大议会厅绘制一幅壮观的战斗场景，描绘一场伟大的佛罗伦萨胜利。当他读到这本书时，这个叫韦斯普奇的人在西塞罗的一封
letters to a famous Greek painter called Apele's. And Cicero describes Apele's as someone who had completed with the most polished art, the head and bust of Venus, but left the other part of her body in Kuwait. Vespucci is very struck by this and he reaches for a pen and he makes a note in the margin and he writes, Apele's the painter. That is what Leonardo da Vinci does in all his pictures, as in the head of Lisa del Giacondo and Anne, the mother of Mary. We will see what he will do in the hall of the Great Council, which he is now contracted to decorate. And then he dates it, 50-03 October.
信中偶然发现了一个关于一位名叫阿佩莱斯（Apelles）的著名希腊画家的参考。西塞罗将阿佩莱斯描述为“以最精湛的技艺完成了维纳斯的头部和胸部，但将其身体的其他部分留为未完成状态”的人。韦斯普奇深受触动，他拿起笔在页边做了一个笔记，写道：“画家阿佩莱斯。这就是列奥纳多·达·芬奇在他所有画作中所做的，比如丽莎·德尔·焦孔多的头部和玛丽的母亲（圣安妮）。我们将看看他在大议会厅会做什么，他现在已经签约装饰那里。”然后他标注了日期，1503年10月。
Whoa. So a massive, massive bombshell. Freud is wrong. Dr. Robert Langdon is wrong. I mean, everyone who thought it wasn't the Mona Lisa is wrong. And so a huge shout out to Dr. Amin Schlechter, who is a librarian in the university library in Heidelberg, and he made the discovery in 2005. And just to list what it proves to make it clear, Vasari was absolutely right. The Mona Lisa is a portrait of Francesco del Giaconda's wife, Lisa Garadini. Leonardo began the painting in 1503, which makes perfect sense because as we said, in 1502, he'd been off in Rome working as chief engineer for Cesare Borgia. And in 1504, of course,
哇。真是个巨大的、巨大的重磅炸弹。弗洛伊德错了。罗伯特·兰登博士错了。我的意思是，所有认为那不是蒙娜丽莎的人都错了。所以要向海德堡大学图书馆的图书管理员阿明·施莱希特（Armin Schlechter）博士大声致敬，他在2005年做出了这一发现。为了清楚起见，列出它证明了什么：瓦萨里（Vasari）完全正确。《蒙娜丽莎》是弗朗切斯科·德尔·焦孔多的妻子丽莎·格拉迪尼的肖像。列奥纳多在1503年开始创作这幅画，这完全说得通，因为正如我们所说，在1502年，他一直在罗马担任切萨雷·博尔吉亚（Cesare Borgia）的首席工程师。当然，在1504年，
he's going to start work on this great battle scene in the La Forentine Council Hall. We also know that Lisa had just given birth to her second son. And so you can imagine that that might be a cause of celebration, something that her husband might want to mark by commissioning a portrait. And we can even work out who might have introduced Leonardo to Francesco because Leonardo's father, Sir Piero, was Francesco's lawyer. And so I think that this clearly in a sense demothologizes the Mona Lisa. It's not a portrait of Leonardo in drag. It's not his mother. It's not the sacred feminine. We can set the commissioning of the Mona Lisa
他将开始在佛罗伦萨议会厅创作那幅伟大的战斗场景。我们还知道丽莎刚刚生下了她的第二个儿子。所以你可以想象这可能是一个庆祝的原因，一个她的丈夫可能想通过委托一幅肖像来纪念的事情。我们甚至可以推断出是谁可能把列奥纳多介绍给了弗朗切斯科，因为列奥纳多的父亲皮耶罗爵士（Sir Piero）是弗朗切斯科的律师。所以我认为这在某种意义上清楚地去除了《蒙娜丽莎》的神话色彩。它不是列奥纳多男扮女装的肖像。它不是他的母亲。它不是神圣的女性。我们可以将《蒙娜丽莎》的委托
absolutely in the context of daily life in Florence these kind of networks of social relations that made the city run family proud businessman commissions lawyers all of this
完全置于佛罗伦萨的日常生活背景中，这些使城市运转的社会关系网络，家庭、骄傲的商人、委托人、律师，所有这些。
so on one level there's no mystery however yeah there are lots of questions aren't there because for example if he did this as a commission why does he not hand it over
所以从一个层面来看，这没有什么神秘的。然而，是的，有很多问题，不是吗？因为例如，如果他是作为委托作品创作的，为什么他不把它交出去
and get paid for it why doesn't he give it to the Gicondo family yeah I mean that's that is a massive question. So, I mean, various answers to that question have been suggested. Maybe the chance to use it as a calling card, as an advertisement for his talents, it ends up being worth more to him than the fee he would have got from Francesco. Maybe he can't bear to finish it. So Vasari in his biography says that Leonardo never finished it. Or maybe, you know, it does have some special meaning for him. Maybe he does
并获得报酬呢？为什么他不把它给焦孔多家族呢？是的，我的意思是，这是一个巨大的问题。所以，关于这个问题已经提出了各种答案。也许他想把它当作一张名片，作为他才华的广告，它对他来说最终比他从弗朗切斯科那里得到的报酬更有价值。也许他无法忍受完成它。所以瓦萨里在他的传记中说列奥纳多从未完成它。或者也许，你知道，它对他确实有某种特殊的意义。也许他确实
see it as his great masterpiece. Maybe he just can't bear to be separated from it. And it's certainly the case that right from the beginning, it is viewed by everyone who sees it as a really revolutionary painting. So the pose of its sitter, the lifelike quality of the portrait, the mysterious quality of the landscape, all of this combines to make it seem to people who come and see it really kind of thrilling, really innovative. So that really surprises me because as a Mona Lisa skeptic as it were, I'd always assumed that the aesthetic value of it was, as it were, projected onto it later. Once it became famous, people said, oh, it's obviously brilliant, blah, blah, blah, but people probably didn't think it was brilliant at the time. But you're telling me that's wrong.
把它视为他伟大的杰作。也许他只是无法忍受与它分离。而且确实从一开始，每个看到它的人都认为它是一幅真正革命性的画作。所以模特的姿势、肖像栩栩如生的品质、风景神秘的品质，所有这些结合在一起，使它在那些来看它的人眼中显得非常令人兴奋，非常具有创新性。这真的让我很惊讶，因为作为一个《蒙娜丽莎》的怀疑论者，我一直认为它的审美价值是后来被投射到它身上的。一旦它出名了，人们就说，哦，它显然很棒，等等，但人们当时可能并不觉得它很棒。但你告诉我那是错的。
And even at the time, for example, other Renaissance painters thought, this is special. Yeah, so Raphael is in Florence at the time when Leonardo is painting it. He comes and sees it, and he's blown away by it. And it's patently a massive influence on. Raphael's painting. And this distinctive pose that the Mona Lisa has, it's very widely copied, so much so that that pose comes to be called the Giaconda. So it's that famous. And by the end of his life, Leonardo has become a tourist attraction in his own right.
即使在当时，例如，其他文艺复兴时期的画家也认为，这很特别。是的，所以拉斐尔在列奥纳多作画时就在佛罗伦萨。他来看了它，并被它震撼了。它显然对拉斐尔的绘画产生了巨大的影响。而《蒙娜丽莎》这种独特的姿势被广泛模仿，以至于那种姿势后来被称为“焦孔多式”。所以它就是那么出名。到他生命结束时，列奥纳多本人已经成为一个旅游景点。
And having the chance to see the Mona Lisa is a part of the package. When people come and visit Leonardo, they want to see this painting. Now, when Leonardo dies, he's not actually in France. He's not even in Italy. He is in France at Embois on the Loire. He dies there on the 2nd of May 1519. And the story is that he dies in the arms of the French king, Francois Prémié, Francis I, because Leonardo had gone to the court of Francis I first in 1516.
而有机会看到《蒙娜丽莎》是其中的一部分。当人们来拜访列奥纳多时，他们想看这幅画。现在，当列奥纳多去世时，他实际上不在意大利。他甚至不在意大利。他在法国卢瓦尔河畔的昂布瓦斯。他于1519年5月2日死在那里。故事是说他死在法国国王弗朗索瓦一世（Francois I）的怀里，因为列奥纳多在1516年首次去了弗朗索瓦一世的宫廷。
And he goes there partly because there are just no patrons worthy of his status who are willing to employ him in Italy. And partly because Francis I really, really wants him and is willing. willing to pay anything. And it actually reminds me a bit of the way in which Mohammed bin Salman, the strong man of Saudi Arabia, paid an obscene amount of money for the Salvatamundi, this painting that has been attributed to Leonardo. There are, you know, there are plenty of people who think it isn't a Leonardo. But it's now gone to Saudi Arabia rather in the way that Leonardo went to the court of Francis I. And when Leonardo dies, Francis I, the first, makes shorter.
他去那里部分是因为在意大利没有值得他地位的赞助人愿意雇佣他。部分是因为弗朗索瓦一世真的、真的很想要他，并且愿意支付任何代价。这实际上让我想起沙特阿拉伯的强人穆罕默德·本·萨勒曼（Mohammed bin Salman）为《救世主》（Salvator Mundi）支付了天价，这幅画被归功于列奥纳多。有很多人认为它不是列奥纳多的作品。但它现在已经去了沙特阿拉伯，就像列奥纳多去了弗朗索瓦一世的宫廷一样。当列奥纳多去世时，弗朗索瓦一世确保
to buy the Mona Lisa. And the result of this is that the painting is going to end up becoming part of the cultural patrimony, not of Italy, but of France. And this is crucial for its future history. So it's become part of French tradition. But in the next couple of centuries, the French don't make a huge amount of it, do they? So for example, in 1625, Louis XIII, actually gives it away. he agrees to give it away to the Duke of Buckingham with his famously long legs, great favourites
买下了《蒙娜丽莎》。结果就是这幅画最终成为了法国，而不是意大利的文化遗产。这对它未来的历史至关重要。所以它成为了法国传统的一部分。但在接下来的几个世纪里，法国人并没有太重视它，对吧？例如，在1625年，路易十三实际上把它送人了。他同意把它送给以长腿著称的白金汉公爵，他是
of James I first. Basically, Buckingham's going to give him a Holbein and I think a Titian. And it's actually Louise Cortius who say, hold on. This is actually quite a good painting. Don't give it away. Yeah, it's such a shame because the Mona Lisa could have ended up in London. See, I think if it had ended up in London, maybe it wouldn't have been such a big deal. I think you're absolutely right. But it is, you're right that kind of for two centuries after Leonardo's death, the painting does go into eclipse. So, you know, it's not showcased. It's not a great treasure of the French king. In 1695, it gets moved to Versailles, but it's put in a pretty obscure corridor. I mean, it's not something that most people would notice. And then in 1750, there's a very clear demonstration of how the
詹姆斯一世的宠臣。基本上，白金汉要给他一幅小汉斯·霍尔拜因（Holbein）的画，我想还有一幅提香（Titian）的画。实际上是路易丝·科蒂斯（Louise Cortius）说，等等。这实际上是一幅相当不错的画。别把它送人。是的，太可惜了，因为《蒙娜丽莎》本可以最终留在伦敦。看，我认为如果它最终留在伦敦，也许它就不会成为这么大的事情了。我想你是完全正确的。但你是对的，在列奥纳多去世后的两个世纪里，这幅画确实进入了低谷。所以，你知道，它没有被展示。它不是法国国王的伟大宝藏。1695年，它被搬到了凡尔赛宫，但被放在了一个相当隐蔽的走廊里。我的意思是，它不是大多数人会注意到的东西。然后在1750年，有一个非常明显的演示，展示了
Mona Lisa is rated, because 110 of the best paintings in the Royal Collection at Versailles are put on display at the Palais de Luxembourg in Paris for the delectation of invited visitors. So 110 paintings, the Mona Lisa is not one of those 110 paintings. So it's not even top 100. So that complicates things because you said right at the beginning, oh, people thought it was amazing right from the start. But obviously now there's a period where people don't think it's amazing. And something changes, doesn't it? That is because Renaissance painting goes out of fashion. There isn't a category of Renaissance painting at that point. And Leonardo's luster has dimmed.
《蒙娜丽莎》的评价如何，因为凡尔赛皇家收藏中110幅最好的画作被陈列在巴黎的卢森堡宫，供受邀的参观者欣赏。所以110幅画，《蒙娜丽莎》不在那110幅画之列。所以它甚至排不进前100名。所以这让事情变得复杂了，因为你在开头说，哦，人们从一开始就认为它很棒。但显然现在有一个时期人们并不认为它很棒。而且有些事情改变了，不是吗？这是因为文艺复兴时期的绘画不再流行了。当时没有“文艺复兴绘画”这一类别。而且列奥纳多的光环也暗淡了。
The posthumous reputation of Leonardo is also bound up with the kind of the decline in the value of the Mona Lisa. So what's changed? What changes and when? Is it the wake of the French Revolution? It's always the French Revolution, isn't it? Yeah. French Revolution is crucial because, of course, suddenly, you know, these paintings are
列奥纳多的身后名声也与《蒙娜丽莎》价值的下降联系在一起。那么是什么改变了？什么改变了，什么时候改变的？是在法国大革命之后吗？总是法国大革命，不是吗？是的。法国大革命至关重要，因为当然，突然之间，你知道，这些画作
not stuffed away in a royal palace. They are being brought out for the people to admire and enjoy. And the revolutionaries set up a great new museum in the Louvre. And the Mona Lisa is moved there. It is briefly transferred to Napoleon's bedroom, along with a load of other paintings. So it's in Napoleon's bedroom from 1800 up to when he becomes emperor in 1804. And the Mona Lisa then goes back to the Louvre. And from that point on, the Mona Lisa is on public display in the world's largest and most prestigious museum.
不再被塞进皇家宫殿里。它们被拿出来供人们欣赏和享受。革命者在卢浮宫建立了一个伟大的新博物馆。而《蒙娜丽莎》被搬到了那里。它曾短暂地与许多其他画作一起被转移到拿破仑的卧室。所以它从1800年到1804年他成为皇帝时一直都在拿破仑的卧室里。然后《蒙娜丽莎》回到了卢浮宫。从那时起，《蒙娜丽莎》就在世界上最大、最负盛名的博物馆里公开展出。
You know, Paris is the acknowledged capital of European high culture. And so it's in the right place now for it to start ascending the list to go up, you know, towards the kind of the top of the pops. But slower process than you would think. So in 1852, there was a list drawn up a sort of estimate of all the artworks in the Louvre. And they ranked their value, didn't they? And the Mona Lisa was ranked at 90,000 francs. But there's a painting by Titian at 150,000. There's one by Raphael at 400,000 francs.
你知道，巴黎是公认的欧洲高雅文化之都。所以它现在处于正确的位置，开始在名单上攀升，走向流行榜的顶端。但过程比你想象的要慢。所以1852年，有人列出了一份清单，对卢浮宫的所有艺术品进行了估价。他们对它们的价值进行了排名，不是吗？《蒙娜丽莎》被评为9万法郎。但有一幅提香的画价值15万。有一幅拉斐尔的画价值40万法郎。
Another Raphael at 600,000 francs. So by those criteria, the Mona Lisa is still a relatively minnow. Yeah. But then progressively, over the course of the 19th century, the Mona Lisa starts to benefit from really quite profound changes in cultural and intellectual tastes. And I guess that the most influential of those is romanticism. You know, it's a very broad brush word, but let's use it as a shorthand.
另一幅拉斐尔的画价值60万法郎。所以按照这些标准，《蒙娜丽莎》仍然是一个相对的小角色。是的。但随后，在19世纪的过程中，随着文化和知识品味的深刻变化，《蒙娜丽莎》开始受益。我想其中最有影响力的是浪漫主义。你知道，这是一个非常宽泛的词，但让我们把它作为一个简写。
So it's shorthand for the worship of genius, admiration for works of art that have a sense of mystery, perhaps of incompletion about them. And of course, a fascination with wild and sublime landscapes. Romantics love a wild and sublime landscape. And all of this massively helps to inflate the reputation of Leonardo, who over the course of 19th century, starts to be seen as not just a genius, but the supreme genius of, as we will see, what comes to be called the Renaissance. And the reason for this is precisely the range of things that he does. You know, he's a painter. He leaves lots of his paintings unfinished. Romantics love that.
所以它是对天才的崇拜、对具有神秘感、或许具有未完成感的艺术作品的钦佩的简写。当然，还有对狂野和崇高风景的迷恋。浪漫主义者热爱狂野和崇高的风景。所有这些都极大地帮助提升了列奥纳多的声誉，他在19世纪的过程中开始被视为不仅是一个天才，而且是我们将要看到的后来被称为“文艺复兴”时期的至高天才。而原因恰恰是他所做事情的范围。你知道，他是一位画家。他留下了许多未完成的画作。浪漫主义者喜欢那样。
But he's also someone who's interested in mountains and tanks and fetuses and swans and eyeballs and everything, just everything. And so, you know, Romantics. love that. And so he comes to be seen as a universal genius. And if he's a universal genius, then what can the Mona Lisa be but a universal woman? So in other words, the fating of Leonardo, the establishment of Leonardo as the archetype of a great genius is the absolutely necessary precondition for the fating of the Mona Lisa as the greatest painting of all times. So to quote Donald's Assune, the Mona Lisa acquired its special status because of its association. And with Leonardo, not the other way round. So I think Leonardo as supreme genius, that is one crucial
但他也是一个对山脉、坦克、胎儿、天鹅、眼球和一切事物都感兴趣的人，简直是一切。所以，你知道，浪漫主义者喜欢那样。因此，他开始被视为一位全才。如果他是一位全才，那么《蒙娜丽莎》除了是一位全能的女性，还能是什么呢？换句话说，对列奥纳多的追捧，将列奥纳多确立为伟大天才的原型，是《蒙娜丽莎》被追捧为史上最伟大画作的绝对必要前提。所以引用唐纳德·萨松的话，《蒙娜丽莎》获得其特殊地位是因为它的关联。是与列奥纳多的关联，而不是反过来。所以我认为列奥纳多作为至高天才，这是对《蒙娜丽莎》声誉膨胀的一个关键
influence on the inflation of the Mona Lisa's reputation. The other one, and this is what Walter Pater is all about, Romantics have a massive thing for predatory females, for fam fatal, as they come to be called. And there's a brilliant book, which was, published way back in 1933, which covers this. It's called The Romantic Agony, translated into English. It's by an Italian critic called Mario Praz. And he writes brilliantly about how over the course of the 19th century, male artists and writers become obsessed with a very distinctive vision of female beauty. And to quote Praz, tainted with pain, corruption, and death. And Praz writes about how by the end of the 19th century, this beauty had to be a very important.
影响。另一个，这就是沃尔特·佩特（Walter Pater）所代表的，浪漫主义者对掠夺性的女性，对后来被称为“蛇蝎美人”（femme fatale）的女性有着巨大的迷恋。有一本精彩的书，早在1933年就出版了，涵盖了这一点。它叫《浪漫的痛苦》（The Romantic Agony），被翻译成英文。作者是一位名叫马里奥·普拉兹（Mario Praz）的意大利评论家。他精彩地写道，在19世纪的过程中，男性艺术家和作家变得痴迷于一种非常独特的女性美愿景。引用普拉兹的话，这种美“沾染了痛苦、腐败和死亡”。普拉兹写道，到19世纪末，这种美必须非常重要。
become illumined with the smile of the geoconda. And this is where Walter Pater comes in. He's a massive, massive influence on the English-speaking world. That passage that you read, I mean, it may seem kind of, you know, purple to us. But it determines how people in the English-speaking world see the Mona Lisa for generations and generations. But the guys who really go big on this are unsurprisingly, since they own it, are the French. So I'll cite two writers in particular.
变得被焦孔多的微笑所照亮。这就是沃尔特·佩特登场的地方。他对英语世界有着巨大、巨大的影响。你读的那段话，我的意思是，对我们来说可能看起来有点华丽。但它决定了英语世界的人们几代人如何看待《蒙娜丽莎》。但真正大肆宣扬这一点的人，不出所料，因为他们拥有它，是法国人。所以我将特别引用两位作家。
And the first is Teofield Gautier, who was a poet, a novelist, a critic. And he is the guy who before Peter establishes Mona Lisa as not just as an archetype of beauty, but as an eternal archetype of beauty. Someone who has essentially existed since the beginning of time. She's older than Egypt. She's older than Greece, older than Rome. So to quote Gautier, she is always there smiling with sensuality, mocking, her numerous lovers. So a bit like Cleopatra there, who Cleopatra was supposed to sleep with men and then kill them. She has the serene countenance of a woman sure that she will remain beautiful
第一位是泰奥菲尔·戈蒂埃（Theophile Gautier），他是一位诗人、小说家、评论家。他是在佩特之前将《蒙娜丽莎》确立为不仅是美的原型，而且是永恒美的原型的人。一个本质上从时间之初就存在的人。她比埃及更古老。她比希腊更古老，比罗马更古老。所以引用戈蒂埃的话，她总是带着感官的、嘲弄的微笑，看着她众多的情人。所以有点像克利奥帕特拉，克利奥帕特拉被认为与男人睡觉然后杀死他们。她拥有那种确信自己将永远美丽
forever and certain to be greater than the ideal of poets and artists. So again, perhaps the hint there of the vampire, someone who is always beautiful, feeding off the blood of her prey. People are projecting an awful lot onto Mona Lisa, aren't they? But, I mean, another example, the historian Jean-Michelais to read an enormous history of the French Revolution. The first historian to use the word Renaissance, by the way, or at least to take it back up from Vasari and to popularize it. And Michelet goes even further, doesn't he? He basically says, you know, the Mona Lisa is a dominatrix?
的女性的宁静面容，并且肯定会比诗人和艺术家的理想更伟大。所以，再次，也许那里有一丝吸血鬼的暗示，一个总是美丽的人，以猎物的鲜血为食。人们在《蒙娜丽莎》身上投射了太多东西，不是吗？但是，我的意思是，另一个例子，历史学家让-米歇尔·米什莱（Jean-Michelet）阅读了一部巨大的法国大革命史。顺便说一句，他是第一位使用“文艺复兴”这个词的历史学家，或者至少是从瓦萨里那里重新拾起并普及它的人。米什莱走得更远，不是吗？他基本上说，你知道，《蒙娜丽莎》是一个施虐者？
Is that going too strong, a dominatrix? Well, you can read what he said about her. This canvas attracts me, revolts me, consumes me, and I go to her in spite of myself as the bird to the snake. But you can see, I mean, this is all kind of very exciting for people in Victorian parlors reading this kind of thing. And of course, as the 19th century goes on towards the 20th century, photography for the first time is starting to be equal to the challenge of capturing the image of the Mona Lisa. So by the end of the 19th century, you've got all this purple prose about vampires and snakes and things. and for the first time
这说得太重了吗，一个施虐者？好吧，你可以读读他关于她的评价。这幅画布吸引我、反抗我、消耗我，我不由自主地走向她，就像鸟儿走向蛇一样。但你可以看出，我的意思是，这对维多利亚时代客厅里读到这些东西的人来说是非常令人兴奋的。当然，随着19世纪走向20世纪，摄影第一次开始有能力捕捉《蒙娜丽莎》的形象。所以到19世纪末，你有了所有这些关于吸血鬼、蛇之类的华丽散文。而且第一次
you have images of the Mona Lisa that are very easy to reproduce and so people can actually look at it without having to go to the Louvre and kind of see it in the flesh as it were. And I would say that by the beginning of the 20th century
你有了非常容易复制的《蒙娜丽莎》图像，所以人们实际上可以看着它，而不必去卢浮宫，也不必亲眼看到它。我会说，到20世纪初
the Mona Lisa is probably the most famous painting in the Louvre, probably one of the most famous paintings in the world. It's kind of had a very meteoric rise. But there's one final thing that's needed to complete. its ascent to the absolute top of the echelon. And this happens on the 21st of August 1911 and what happens puts the Mona Lisa on the front page of newspapers
《蒙娜丽莎》可能是卢浮宫最著名的画作，可能是世界上最著名的画作之一。它经历了一次非常迅速的崛起。但还有最后一件事需要完成。它攀升到绝对顶峰。这发生在1911年8月21日，发生的事情让《蒙娜丽莎》登上了报纸的头版
around the world. So 21st of August 1911 it's a Monday and the Louvre is shut for cleaning. While it's shut people walk through the room in which the Mona Lisa is kept and they find that it's gone. There is only the empty frame in which it had been contained. And there is complete outrage. The director of France's museums is sacked. The Petit Parisienne, which at the time was the world's largest circulation newspaper, splashed the painting on the front page together with the brilliantly caustic comment.
全世界。所以1911年8月21日，那是一个星期一，卢浮宫关闭进行清洁。当它关闭时，人们走过存放《蒙娜丽莎》的房间，发现它不见了。只剩下它曾经装在里面的空画框。这引起了极大的愤怒。法国博物馆馆长被解雇了。《小巴黎人报》（Petit Parisienne），当时是世界上发行量最大的报纸，将这幅画印在头版，并配上了精彩而尖刻的评论。
Well, at least we still have the frame. The news goes around Paris, around France, around the world. Huge crowds kind of descend on the louvre. go to look at where the painting had been much larger crowds than had ever assembled when the Mona Lisa was actually in situ. And there's a desperate kind of Inspector Cluzo-type pursuit of the painting, which is always raking up ludicrous suspect. So one of them is the famous poet, Guillaume Apollinaire, who is arrested. And Apollinaire and a friend of his, who is an up-and-coming Spanish painter resident in Paris at the time called Pablo Picasso, actually end up on trial, both Apollinaire.
好吧，至少我们还有画框。消息传遍了巴黎、法国和全世界。巨大的人群涌向卢浮宫。去看看画作曾经所在的地方，人数比《蒙娜丽莎》还在原位时聚集的人群还要多。而且有一种绝望的、类似克鲁索探长（Inspector Cluzo）式的对画作的追捕，总是翻出荒谬的嫌疑人。其中之一是著名的诗人纪尧姆·阿波利奈尔（Guillaume Apollinaire），他被捕了。阿波利奈尔和他的一个朋友，当时居住在巴黎的一位崭露头角的西班牙画家巴勃罗·毕加索（Pablo Picasso），实际上最终受审，阿波利奈尔和
and Picasso are acquitted. It's a suggestion of how this crime is not only inflating the reputation of the Mona Lisa, but is also kind of rubbing up against artists and poets and painters who are the cutting edge of the avant-garde, which I think is another part of why the Mona Lisa suddenly comes to seem much more interesting to people than it had previously done. However, the police seem helpless. A year passes, there are no leads, and by 1913, so that's a couple of years after the theft, the Mona Lisa is removed from the catalogue of the Louvre. It's basically an admission of defeat. You know, this painting is gone. We're never going to get it back. But then, as dramatically as it had vanished, the Mona Lisa reappears. And it reappears because in Florence, where of course
毕加索都被宣告无罪。这表明了这起犯罪不仅提升了《蒙娜丽莎》的声誉，而且还与当时处于前卫艺术尖端的艺术家、诗人和画家产生了碰撞，我认为这是《蒙娜丽莎》突然变得比以前更让人们感兴趣的另一个原因。然而，警察似乎束手无策。一年过去了，没有任何线索，到1913年，也就是盗窃案发生几年后，《蒙娜丽莎》从卢浮宫的目录中被删除了。这基本上是承认失败。你知道，这幅画不见了。我们永远找不回它了。但随后，就像它消失时一样戏剧性，《蒙娜丽莎》重新出现了。它重新出现是因为在佛罗伦萨，当然
the Mona Lisa had originally been painted, an antique dealer, called Alfredo Jerry gets a letter which has been signed Leonardo. And in this letter, Leonardo says that he wants to hand over the Mona Lisa to the Afizi, the great gallery in Florence, and he hints that he wants to do this for patriotic reasons. He does also say that he wants 500,000 dearer to cover his expenses, but he's going very big on the fact that he's Italian and he's doing this for patriotic reasons. So the antique dealer arranges to meet him and Leonardo, Julie arrives from Paris and Jerry and the head curator from the Ephizi asked to see the Mona Lisa. He kind of pulls the Mona Lisa out from his suitcase, unwraps it.
《蒙娜丽莎》最初是在那里绘制的，一位名叫阿尔弗雷多·杰里（Alfredo Jerry）的古董商收到了一封署名“列奥纳多”的信。在这封信中，列奥纳多说他想把《蒙娜丽莎》交给乌菲兹美术馆（Afizi），即佛罗伦萨的伟大画廊，他暗示他想出于爱国原因这样做。他也确实说他想要50万第纳尔来支付他的费用，但他非常强调他是意大利人，他这样做是出于爱国原因。所以古董商安排见他，列奥纳多·朱利（Leonardo Julie）从巴黎赶来，杰里和乌菲兹美术馆的首席馆长要求看《蒙娜丽莎》。他从手提箱里拿出《蒙娜丽莎》，拆开包装。
The head curator of the Ephizzi inspects it. It's clear it is indeed the Mona Lisa. And so they have the thief arrested. And he turns out to be a guy called Vincenzo Perugia. And he was an Italian painter-decorator who had been working in the Louvre, painting the walls on the Fateful Monday that the painting was stolen. And he seized his chance. And he just lifted it out from his frame, hidden it under his coat, walked off across the courtyard of the Louvre. He kind of waved at a guard and gone out through the door.
乌菲兹美术馆的首席馆长检查了它。很明显，它确实是《蒙娜丽莎》。于是他们逮捕了小偷。他原来是一个名叫文森佐·佩鲁贾（Vincenzo Perugia）的人。他是一位意大利油漆工兼装饰工，在那个命运攸关的星期一，他一直在卢浮宫工作，粉刷墙壁。他抓住了机会。他只是把它从画框里取出来，藏在外套下，走过卢浮宫的庭院。他向守卫挥了挥手，从门口走了出去。
And that was that. And he kept it for a year and a half hidden under his bed. And, you know, his motivation, which he holds to throughout his subsequent trial, is that he was outraged that the Mona Lisa was in Paris. He thought it should be in Florence. And one of the reasons why he's so outraged is he thought that Napoleon had stolen it from the Ephizzi. So this was his motivation. And there's no reason to doubt that he was genuinely suffused with kind of nationalist enthusiasm, is that?
事情就是这样。他把它藏在床下一年半。而且，你知道，他在随后的审判中一直坚持的动机是，他对《蒙娜丽莎》在巴黎感到愤怒。他认为它应该在佛罗伦萨。他感到如此愤怒的原因之一是他认为拿破仑是从乌菲兹美术馆偷走它的。所以这就是他的动机。没有理由怀疑他确实充满了某种民族主义的热情，是吗？
The problem is he turns out to be really boring. You know, people had wanted a master criminal, a kind of gentleman, cracksman, and he's not at all. And because he does not become the focus of media retention, which he might otherwise have done, instead, the star is Mona Lisa. And what previously the painting had been called it, it's from this point on that the Mona Lisa starts to be feminized. The Mona Lisa is she. She is coming back to Paris.
问题是他原来真的很无聊。你知道，人们想要一个大师级罪犯，一个绅士窃贼，但他根本不是。因为他没有成为媒体关注的焦点（他本可以成为焦点），相反，明星是《蒙娜丽莎》。这幅画以前被称为“它”，从这一点开始，《蒙娜丽莎》开始被女性化。《蒙娜丽莎》是“她”。她正在回到巴黎。
She is returning to the Louvre. She is being put back in her frame. And when she is put back in her frame in the Louvre, she sits from that point on as the absolute symbol, the absolute embodiment of high art, of high culture, with capital letters. And from that point on, the reputation of the Mona Lisa as the embodiment of the Renaissance of Western art, of art, full stop, is absolutely secure, although it does have the kind of paradoxical effect that now the Mona Lisa is the icon of high art. Of course, enthusiasts of high art start to turn against it and to say, oh, it's a bit vulgar, it's a bit trashy.
她正在回到卢浮宫。她正在被放回她的画框里。当她被放回卢浮宫的画框时，从那时起，她就成为了高雅艺术、高雅文化的绝对象征，绝对化身，大写字母的。从那时起，《蒙娜丽莎》作为文艺复兴、西方艺术、艺术（句号）的化身的声誉绝对稳固了，尽管它产生了一种矛盾的效果，即现在《蒙娜丽莎》是高雅艺术的偶像。当然，高雅艺术的爱好者开始反对它，说，哦，它有点庸俗，有点垃圾。
She becomes the embodiment of middlebrow art enthusiasm, doesn't she? I mean, isn't that the, you know, somebody, if you're a student and you go in and somebody's got a printer the Mona Lisa on their wall, you kind of think you don't really know much about art. Do you not think? Yeah, it's the classic FM of art. But this in turn, of course, I mean, it only fuels her further assent into the stratosphere of fame. And you can see it operating in all kinds of ways. So because she's famous, because people are meant to take her seriously in.
她成了平庸艺术热情的化身，不是吗？我的意思是，如果你是个学生，走进某人的房间，看到墙上贴着一张《蒙娜丽莎》的印刷品，你大概会觉得这个人对艺术了解不多，你不觉得吗？是的，这就是艺术界的经典“调频广播”。但这当然进一步助推了她向名声的平流层攀升。你可以看到它在各种层面上发挥作用。因为她出名，因为人们理应认真对待她。
and kind of offer her obeisance, of course she starts to be parodied. And the most famous of these parodies is done in 1919, so only, you know, a few years after her abduction and return. And this is done by the artist Marcel Duchamp, who's also very keen on urinals. And he gets a postcard of the Mona Lisa, and he draws a moustache and a goatee on it. And he calls it in English, uses the letters L-H-O-O-Q, but Dominique. with your mastery of French. Do you want to just explain to people
并对她表示某种敬意，她自然就开始被恶搞了。其中最著名的恶搞发生在1919年，也就是她被盗并找回后的几年。这是由艺术家马塞尔·杜尚完成的，他本人也非常热衷于小便池。他买了一张《蒙娜丽莎》的明信片，在上面画了胡子和山羊胡。他用英语称呼它，用了L-H-O-O-Q这几个字母，但多米尼克，以你精通法语的水平，你想给听众解释一下吗？
what that means in French? It's a tremendous example of French humor. L-H-O-O-O-Q, in French is L-H-O-Q, which means she is hot, basically, she's hot in the ass. She's hot in the bind. So tremendous banter there from Marcel Dichon. Outrage and consternation,
这在法语里是什么意思？这是一个极好的法式幽默例子。L-H-O-O-Q在法语里读作“Elle a chaud au cul”，意思是她很火辣，基本上就是说她屁股很烫。她在发情。所以马塞尔·杜尚开了个极好的玩笑。愤怒和惊愕，
and of course the scandal just further amplifies the Mona Lisa's fame. Then, of course, there's mass reproduction. So the more scope for reproducing the Mona Lisa, the more she's reproduced. And it's really telling that in 1963, she is the first painting to be reproduced by Andy Warhol. I mean, that's the true measure of fame. And Warhol had been inspired to do it by the fact that in 1963, the Mona Lisa had come to America, a kind of diplomatic gift from DeGold to Kennedy.
当然，丑闻进一步放大了《蒙娜丽莎》的名声。然后，当然还有大规模复制。复制《蒙娜丽莎》的机会越多，她被复制的次数就越多。1963年，她成为安迪·沃霍尔复制的第一幅画作，这非常能说明问题。我的意思是，这是名声的真正衡量标准。沃霍尔之所以受到启发，是因为1963年《蒙娜丽莎》来到了美国，这是戴高乐送给肯尼迪的一种外交礼物。
And so that makes the Mona Lisa even more famous in America than in the United. 1974, it visits Japan, and that kind of lights the fuse on Japanese enthusiasm for going to the Louvre and taking photographs of the Mona Lisa. And I would say that it's not an exaggeration that now the Mona Lisa ranks not just as the archetype of high art, but kind of as the ultimate global icon of tourism. I mean, it's the one object in the world, probably that tourists, the massive tourists want to see more than anything else. I mean, it is the single most popular object held by any museum in the world. And the Louvre is the most visited museum. You have nine million people going there a year. And I think according to surveys, more than half of
这使得《蒙娜丽莎》在美国比在英国更出名。1974年，它访问了日本，这点燃了日本人前往卢浮宫并拍摄《蒙娜丽莎》照片的热情。我认为毫不夸张地说，现在《蒙娜丽莎》不仅是高雅艺术的原型，更是全球旅游业的终极标志。我的意思是，它可能是世界上游客最想看的物品。它是世界上任何博物馆收藏的最受欢迎的单一物品。卢浮宫是参观人数最多的博物馆，每年有九百万人前往。我认为根据调查，超过一半的
those people say that they're going specifically to see the Mona Lisa. So it now has its own dedicated room. It's got its own kind of crowd management procedures. It's got its own security arrangements, but it's still kind of messing up the ability of the Louvre to present all its other paintings, because the curators in the Louvre have always insisted that the Mona Lisa be presented as a Renaissance painting, so alongside other Renaissance paintings. And the effect is that people just, you know, they rush past all the other Renaissance paintings, including Leonardo's picture of John the Baptist, and they all kind of gather around the Mona Lisa. And so the plan now, this is part of President Macron's kind of a post.
这些人说他们专门是为了看《蒙娜丽莎》而去的。所以它现在有了自己的专属展厅，有自己的人流管理程序，有自己的安保安排，但这仍然在某种程度上干扰了卢浮宫展示其他画作的能力，因为卢浮宫的策展人一直坚持将《蒙娜丽莎》作为文艺复兴时期的画作来展示，即与其他文艺复兴时期的画作并列。结果就是人们匆匆走过所有其他文艺复兴时期的画作，包括列奥纳多的《施洗者圣约翰》，然后全都聚集在《蒙娜丽莎》周围。所以现在的计划，这是马克龙总统某种后
Holianist ambitions, his grand project, is going to be his kind of final legacy project, and he's called it the New Renaissance. So the Mona Lisa is going to be moved to an underground gallery. It's going to be entirely exclusive to the Mona Lisa. There will be no other work of art inside it, and that is scheduled to open in 2013. So Lisa Gerardini will end up having a very own suite of rooms in the most visited museum in the world. And I think that I love it that an otherwise entirely obscure Florentine woman is so astronomically insanely famous. Such an interesting story. And yet, I have to say, I find it quite an unbelievably uninteresting painting. But it is a fascinating story. I think the more I trace the history of how it's come to be famous. And the many ways in which it's
霍利安主义野心的一部分，他的宏大项目，将成为他最终的遗产项目，他称之为“新文艺复兴”。因此，《蒙娜丽莎》将被移到一个地下画廊。它将完全专属于《蒙娜丽莎》，里面不会有其他艺术品，计划于2030年开放。所以丽莎·格拉迪尼最终将在世界上参观人数最多的博物馆里拥有自己的一套房间。我喜欢这样一个事实：一位原本完全默默无闻的佛罗伦萨女性竟然如此疯狂地出名。这是一个非常有趣的故事。然而，我不得不说，我觉得这幅画本身令人难以置信地乏味。但这是一个迷人的故事。我想我越是追溯它成名的历史，以及它被理解的多种方式，
been understood, the more you can see that all these, everything that people have seen in it is kind of there. I mean, it is kind of infinite in the ways that it can be interpreted and seen. And that might not be true of other paintings. I think the story is so interesting. And it's such an interesting case study in art history and art criticism. But frankly, as a painting, I can think of hundreds of paintings I'd rather look at than the mainly say, anyway, that does not in any way diminish the story, which is fascinating. Tom, Thank you very much and Arrivedeci.
我就越能看出人们在画中看到的一切其实都在那里。我的意思是，它在解读和观看方式上是无限的。这可能不适用于其他画作。我认为这个故事非常有趣，它是艺术史和艺术评论中一个非常有趣的案例研究。但坦率地说，作为一幅画，我可以想到数百幅我更愿意看的画，而不是《蒙娜丽莎》。无论如何，这丝毫没有削弱这个故事的魅力，它非常迷人。汤姆，非常感谢，再见。
Bye-bye. Why did we really go to war with Iraq? And did Saddam Hussein really have weapons of mass destruction? I'm Gordon Carrera, National Security Journalist. And I'm David McCloskey, author and former CIA analyst. We are the hosts of The Rest is Classified and in our latest series, we are telling the true story of one of history's biggest intelligence failures,
再见。我们为什么真的要和伊拉克开战？萨达姆·侯赛因真的有大规模杀伤性武器吗？我是国家安全记者戈登·卡雷拉。我是作家兼前中情局分析师大卫·麦克洛斯基。我们是《Rest is Classified》的主持人，在我们最新的系列节目中，我们讲述了历史上最大的情报失败之一的真实故事，
Iraq WMD. In 2003, the US and you have, The UK told the world that Saddam Hussein had weapons of mass destruction, but they were wrong. This wasn't a simple lie, it was something far more complicated, far more interesting, and far more dangerous. Spies who believed their sources, politicians who wanted the public to believe in the threat, and a dictator who couldn't prove he'd already destroyed the weapons. In this series, we go deep inside the CIA and MI6, go into the rooms where decisions were made. were made and look at the sources who fabricated the intelligence that took us to war.
伊拉克大规模杀伤性武器。2003年，美国和英国告诉世界萨达姆·侯赛因拥有大规模杀伤性武器，但他们错了。这不仅仅是一个简单的谎言，它要复杂得多，有趣得多，也危险得多。相信自己线人的间谍，希望公众相信威胁的政客，以及无法证明自己已经销毁武器的独裁者。在这个系列中，我们将深入中情局和军情六处，走进决策室，审视那些编造了将我们带入战争的情报的来源。
The Iraq War reshaped the Middle East and permanently weakened public trust in governments and intelligence agencies, and its consequences are still playing out today. Plus, in a declassified club exclusive, we are joined by three people who were at the heart of the decision to go to war. Former head of MI6, Richard Deerlove, Tony Blair's former communications director, Alistair Campbell, and former acting head of the CIA, Michael Morel. So get the full story by listening to The Rest is Classified and subscribing to the Declassified Club
伊拉克战争重塑了中东，并永久性地削弱了公众对政府和情报机构的信任，其后果至今仍在显现。此外，在“解密俱乐部”的独家节目中，我们邀请了三位处于战争决策核心的人物：前军情六处负责人理查德·迪尔洛夫、托尼·布莱尔的前通讯主管阿拉斯泰尔·坎贝尔，以及前中情局代理局长迈克尔·莫雷尔。所以，请收听《Rest is Classified》并订阅“解密俱乐部”，获取完整故事，
wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
无论你在哪里收听播客。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。